e
e e
good morning and welcome to the house
executive departments and administration
committee meeting um I would like to
open up our hearing for House Bill
216 um and representative Maguire you're
ready to
present good morning I'm Carol Maguire
repr representing marac District 27 that
is Allenstown Dunbarton Epsom and
hookset and House Bill 26 fixes a glitch
we discovered last year when we were
dealing with people who are severely
injured on the
job it
deletes the
requirement oh the limitation of one
year of
um workers compensation that is credited
towards one retirement service not
income just service time
and we I looked into that at the end of
the year and no one is quite sure where
that limitation came from it seems to be
rather
arbitrary and from the testimony
received last year there are very very
few people who are injured and out on
workers comp for more than in a year
it's only the people who are grievously
injured on the job someone who is in a
you know got run over by a snowplow or
got shot in action or something like
that it's not your your normal case
because uh most people are easily um
back on the job within a year it's only
these rare cases where they have M
multiple surgeries and lengthy
recuperation that they get hit
so the fiscal note in my opinion is a
bit exaggerated I don't know how many
people would be out
on
uh on workers comp for more than a year
but I can't imagine it's
10% um so I think it's it there is going
to be some re reprogramming cost I agree
with that but the actual impact should
be much less than the uh the fiscal note
indicates and that's um that's it I'll
answer any questions I
can representative sers thank you madam
chair um representative
Maguire there seems to be some unknowns
in this case like you're saying we don't
know how many people are out more than a
year is there any way we can find out
this information and what maybe the cost
would really
be uh probably not in any timely manner
but we can certainly ask for how many
people have run into this limit at least
within the last few years
um I'll
ask representative G gr thank you um
representative Maguire if my memory
serves correctly last year there were
only two people who had test
ified so that I don't and I believe that
they were the only two that would have
been eligible had this legislation been
implemented just we don't know that to
be absolutely true because it would not
have included say the person run over by
a snowplow it only included uh police
who were injured on shot on the job um
there we know of those it affected one
of those two it we don't think it
affected the other um but there may well
have been others in the
past are there other questions
representative sellers thank you so
another question I have is uh how would
this affect
uh insurance rate basically a rate that
we pay or someone pays into uh work as
comp shouldn't affect it anyway in any
at all because these people are in
injured the workers comp system
determines that it's job related and
pays them from workers
comp uh the difference is that right now
after a year of workers comp for one
incident they no longer get service
towards their retirement it's purely in
the pension system workers's comp is
unaffected
it might in the only thing is that it
might possibly encourage somebody who's
been out
for uh TW 11 and a half months to stay
out a little longer on workers comp but
I I can't imagine that being a a big
issue thank you and it's my
understanding that this is an early bill
so this will be going to finance as well
so we'll be able to they'll be able to
ask some of those hard questions I'll
ask that they report on how many people
have run into the limit which is I think
the thing we want to find
out thank you and that representative
salers yeah thank you I'm just trying to
find out because I'm new at this Edna
and um work as comp and what type of
benefits uh employees have especially in
an accident like something like that on
the job I mean are there other benefits
available to the worker at that point
and that's what this is about extending
the extending the benefit here of
working comp more than I believe I
believe
that and you'd have we have another bill
on workers
comp um applying to people in in the um
in the pension system later on that'll
have some of those details but my
understanding is that uh their their
health benefits are continued while
they're on workers comp and they they
get the base payment from the workers
comp system of which I know nothing more
than that that it exists and some
employers at least will give a
supplement to the workers's comp amount
which is I believe fairly
low uh but that's up to the
employer and I don't don't know which
ones do or for how
much so I have a question for you as
well um right the way that I'm reading
this is seems that if somebody was out
on workers compensation for two years
they would have one year of service
added to that pension but that other
year just wouldn't count towards the
pension the only impact this has is on
calculating the years of service is that
correct yes the um the people that I'm
thinking of are probably not going to be
out on a year continuously this
the stories we got were that somebody
had surgery recovered went back to work
for a while and strengthened themselves
and then had another surgery and went
out again so uh like you said it's the
only thing that should be affected is
the time towards toward
retirement thank you any oh
representative uh representative
Schmidt it's early yeah so I I think a
little bit of
historical information can be helpful
especially for people you represent
Sellers and others who are new to Edna
so we have been tinkering with the with
the retirement system and with the
workers comp and so forth
for about the the entire time I've been
on the committee which is 18 years okay
the first step was um for people who get
killed on the job uh that's most mostly
police or
firefighters who get killed on the job
okay and so we decided about 20 years
ago to uh to try to help those the
families because people get killed on
the job they're out of the picture right
it's their family that's harmed by the
loss of their loved one their spouse and
so forth so the the first decision made
was that we were going to
provide a death benefit for for people
who got killed on the job right and and
uh that was decided to be
$100,000 over the years that that that
we're talking about roughly 20 years
there are very few people in that
category who get killed on the job okay
fortunately what fortun of course
fortunately um so the first question was
where's that money going to come from
and the the
initial idea was to uh
to basically basically do that through
an insurance
policy but the thought was because there
were so few people involved in that
category that the insurance companies
were still going to you know because the
The Genius of insurance is you spread
the risk right if it's a very very small
number of people there's no there's no
insurance coming in from the thing to to
uh to make
that profitable for the insurance
companies therefore they won't they
won't provide the service without
enormously High premiums so the decision
that was made was that the state would
provide that $100,000 benefit out of the
general fund because it's such a small
number of people and that's the way it's
working out the state pays that $100,000
out of the general fund be because the
number of people involved is so small
it's been next to nothing over the years
then we had a situation A couple of
years ago where we had a a very small
number of people who were grievously
injured or killed
intentionally we had a some of you who
who are from the central area who are
read the new the Manchester Union leader
in large numbers there was a police
officer Dan dhy is his name um who was
shot at
intentionally like 14 times the the the
would be
assassin uh shot at him 14 times and he
hit him six
times now ordinarily somebody who gets
shot six times is going to die right yes
um representative um I actually realized
that there may be some other people that
are here to testify on this and well
then and it would be good to get into
some of this as the committee is able to
discuss this as a committee but I do
want to check that I apprciate people to
testify let's hear from them okay but
this is this is a different group of
people but they still are in comparable
situation so let's hear from them
absolutely thank you representative
Schmidt are there any other questions
for chairman Maguire or sorry
representative Maguire
thank you very
much are there others who are interested
in testifying on
this that would be
helpful who are you and if you could
give your name again um you just turned
off the microphone when you pressed that
red was
off go ahead you can fill it out yeah um
my name is Mark kavar I'm Deputy counsel
and compliance officer for the New
Hampshire retirement
system and uh one of my responsibilities
to complete the fiscal note
worksheets and um in doing this one we
reached out to the Department of Labor
to ask them if they had statistics that
could provide us with the number of
people who
remain on weekly Indemnity benefits for
more than a year and they were unable to
provide that they said they do not
compile the data that way and so our
actuary had no choice except to pick a
starting point and that's the six months
10% parameters that are in the fiscal
note worksheet um it was just a starting
point I don't want to say it was
completely arbitrary it was fairly
conservative but the number that they
presented is fully scalable if you think
it's 5% cut the number in half if you
thinks it's three months instead of six
months cut the number in half so so it's
fully scalable if you have a different
opinion but again labor was unable to
provide the
information uh which would have been
very helpful I was hoping they could but
they they just I talked to the
commissioner and they just don't um
compile the data that way and the
commissioner on our Board of Trustees so
if they had it they would have given it
to us um just to speak to how workers
comp is treated by New Hampshire
retirement system when someone goes out
on workers comp they're entitled to
weekly Indemnity benefit that which is
60% of their average compensation over a
period of time prior to the
injury um employers will sometimes
supplement that with the other 40%
because that money is paid by an
insurance company and not by the
employer it's not considered earnable
compensation and since the member is not
receiving any earnable compensation they
don't receive service credit and that's
why the current one-year rule is in I
don't know the history I look back I
it's been around for many many years I
don't know why they picked the one year
um but from you know it's a policy
question whether you want to extend it
uh we don't view it as being super
expensive and uh we we have no position
on whether it's a good or a bad idea but
there is a distinction between those who
were on a year and those who were on for
more than a year now one thing I would
say is that a lot of people been on for
more than a year may be eligible to
apply for a work-related Disability
Pension and that's and a lot of them do
after that point they said well I can't
go back to work and I'll apply for a
Disability Pension through nhrs so that
that's why you don't see a lot of cases
of people complaining that they because
at that
point um a lot of people also
will once they go on disability will
convert their weekly Indemnity benefit
to a lumpsum settlement because when
you're on disability we offset your
disability benefit by the weekly
Indemnity benefit paid by workers
comp and so as soon as someone gets on
disability they lump some whatever
whatever the projected
course of years for further payments
that they agree to with the workers's
comp carrier because once they lump
Summit they we're not offsetting anymore
so it's much more valuable for them so
it kind of weeds out more people like
that as well um plus if anyone's
retiring they're not getting service
credit anymore anyways once you retire
but that's a reason why a lot of people
stop receiving weekly Indemnity benefits
because it's advantageous they can
retire under accidental benefit and and
then lump sum their payment with the uh
workers
comp representative scitec do you have a
question two questions one is uh your
would you confirm that workers comp does
not contribute to earnable compensation
it is not earnable compensation because
and contributions are not paid on it by
the member or the employer because it's
not paid by the employer it's paid by
thank you would you mind insurance
company would you yes would you mind
repeating that offset business I'm not
sure I understood that our statute
provides that if you are receiving an
accidental disability benefit meaning
work related and you're receiving a
weekly Indemnity benefit from workers
comp we will offset your disability
benefit by the amount of the weekly
Indemnity
benefit and I guess this has been around
for years and I guess the theory was
well you shouldn't be paid tce for the
same injury by two
different that's the theory I guess I
wasn't around when it went in place I've
seen various legislation in the past to
do away with that but they they haven't
passed um thank you uh representative
sellers yeah thank you so that offset is
that offset so that makes up the other
40% no no no so say they have a
disability benefit of 2500 a
month and work as comp's paying them a
th000 500 a week well we'd offset their
benefit by 2,000 a month by 500 a week
times four so we offset the benefit the
other
40% if paid by the employer and that's
optional like nashille firefighters I
know has it but it's not very common
it's called workers comps upal pay where
through CVA agreements they agree to pay
the other 40% to to make a person Hall
60% from workers comp that is workers
that is um earnable compensation and
that's what the other bill is about
because we it's currently classified as
compensation overbased and the other
workers comp bill that you'll be
entertaining later is suggesting that it
be counted as base and not compensation
over base which can have some effect on
benefits but that's a different Bill
representative
citech but that as earnable compensation
wouldn't really mean anything to to
their pension because you take the high
highest five years and something like a
40% is not really going to contribute so
um yeah it depends on how long you've
been on disability and collecting it
average compensation is calculated in 12
month tranches so if you make enough
money in the rest the rest of the year
when you're not injured it may still be
one of your high three or high five
years but it's guess work on the math um
and I have a question for you as you
were looking for the information did you
look to your records to see how many
people did have um time off that did not
get counted towards the um serviceable
credit uh no we our records only show
what credit we've awarded to people for
that first year they they have to
provide us a memo of compensability and
and then they're showing the start date
and the end date
and we would record that and our
assistant the service credit awarded but
we don't record what wasn't awarded or
or it just wasn't something we kept
track of okay thank you it's helpful to
know that D those data don't exist um
and then the last question are you do
you know whether people are more
incentivized to go for the service
related Disability Pension um if they're
going to be out more than a year so that
they don't lose that
coverage I I couldn't speak to people's
personal
motivations thank you there other
questions see n thank you very much and
thanks for being here so that we could
do that if you get the pink card to him
then we can have you in the record thank
you is there anybody else here to speak
on
this with this we will close that
hearing is should we consider going into
an executive session to discuss this so
we'll go um I will close the a public
hearing on House Bill uh
216 and I will open an executive session
on House Bill
216 you want me to slide over it's
probably
easiest representative Lon you're name
tags are reversed there
thank you very
much easily
fixed does someone have a
motion I'll move a to pass on House Bill
216 all right and I'll second
it all right representative groer thank
you Madame chair I just um first of all
want to remind the committee that we're
voting on policy
and that the fiscal the uh Finance um
division will determine whether or not
this is something we can put into our
budget or not and so the policy that we
are voting on is
that um if a work someone who who has
experienced an accident and
is
um out of work for a year or more that
that time is not is not um deducted from
their
pension and that's really what we're
saying we're saying that if someone's
injured in the case of the the person
that testified last year they had been
injured
for they were in the hospital I think
the first for 14 months to have their
first surgery and then to have their
second surgery a year later they were
out of again for a long period of time
and when they thought they were could
retire they were really trying to stay
in the workforce until for 10 years but
then when they and not realizing that
their Workman time their workman's
compensation time was deducted from
their um work from their pension work
time they ended up working eight years
so they were it was they were penalized
for that and I think that when someone
is Gravely injured like that they
shouldn't have that penalty so I hope
that you will agree that as a policy
this committee should support the
bill and thank you represent fra I'll
mention that as I said I think the idea
that 10% of the population is going to
be out for more than a year is highly
exaggerated and
U I would say it's if it's 1% I'd be
surprised the U last year year when we
were talking about firefight uh police
who had been injured on the job and
severely injured and had to retire on
disability because of it because they
didn't
die
um after much searching they could only
Identify two people that it had happened
to and I think that's a much more
realistic number than 10% of the
population um so we'll see what the
um what comes out of it but I we're
trying to find out how many people are
are there are would be affected by this
and I think um as representative groa
said I think we owe it to the people
that
are severely injured on the job to at
least recognize
it presid citech just a minute if we're
not going to be fair on this issue what
issue are we going to be fair on
well probably
not any other representativ L uh thank
you madam chair uh my question is if um
the conditions around workman's
compensation are something that's
handled with the legislature or if
that's set through other policy uh it's
it's set through other policy workers
comp issues are done mostly in the labor
committee and I have they're the experts
on what's job related and what's what's
not and how long somebody should be out
for a particular injury uh they're they
do this all the time that's their entire
job so this bill doesn't say anything
about that you know it just talks about
the result of having of being out on
workers
comp okay any other comments questions
yes we're lay on uh thank you um that
makes me feel a lot more comfortable
with this because if we had epidemic of
long workers compensations for hang
nails um that would be a problem but if
we're setting the policy elsewhere in
the legislature then I feel comfortable
that we will only have people out who
truly should be out and that that makes
me feel a lot more comfortable than if
some other body was making those
decisions thank you it's it's workers
comp is well established policy we've
had it
for
Generations any other
comments all right seeing then none the
motion is ought to pass by
representative broa and the clerk can
call the
role Vice chairman Lon yes clerk votes
yes representative
Bailey
I I okay
uh translate yeah um representative Shan
yes representative sellers
yes representative
groa yes representative
Schmidt
yes representative
Davis yes representative dargy
yes representative St of re
yes representative La yes and the chair
did you get representative
Howard I'm
over to your left sorry he the invisible
representative Howard yeah no worries I
I vote Yes and the chair yes okay um I
guess we're looking at uh 13 eyes no
nose all right the motion passes 13 to
zero is there any objection to
consent seeing none we'll put that on
consent representative groda at your
earliest convenience
all right we also we still have a few
minutes so I'd like to continue to exact
some of the bills that we heard last
week um I move ought to pass on House
Bill
85 and I present Amendment 00
37h which I passed out earlier I second
all right this amendment is simply to
incorporate the language requested by
oplc which is temporary student
license um in all
cases and so
um that that's it about the amendment
and represent Gro do you wish to uh say
anything about the
amendment no thank you I think you said
it all any other questions or comments
on the
amendment 37 yes it is I put it at your
place every morning this
morning yeah
it's pretty
minor
right
right that case the motion is to adopt
amendment
0037 to House Bill 885 and you can call
the
role Vice chairman L
yes the clerk votes yes representative
Bailey I representative Shan yes
representative sers yes representative
groa yes representative Schmidt yes
representative
Davis yes
representative Dary
yes representative Heath
yes uh representative Heath Howard I'm
sorry uh representative du re
yes representative long yes and the
chair yes the same 13 Z all right then I
move a to pass with Amendment on House
Bill
85 second second by representative
Schmid and to recap this
is a bill to allow a student respiratory
therapist to
work with what they've already learned
in their I believe it's a two-year
course so a seconde student can be
employed with what they learned in the
first year
um under supervision and only what they
have
um have learned which
is it's supported by the hospital
Association and not opposed by anybody
so U I think it's a very simple
idea represent
Schmid I have nothing further to add
okay anyone else comments
questions all right seeing none the
motion is ought to pass with Amendment
on house hospit
85 and the clerk and call the rooll vice
chair Alon yes cler yes representative
Bailey I representative Sheen yes
representative sers yes representative
groa yes representative Schmidt yes
representative Davis yes representative
dargy yes representative Howard yes got
it right this time representative D re
yes representative long yes and the
chair yes 130 are there any the motion
passes 13 to zero any objections to
consent all right I will write a blur my
earliest
convenience
and all right's the other Bill we heard
last
we ah okay
considering House Bill
267 which is the animal chiropractors
does somebody have a motion on
that I'll move OTP did somebody else say
something I
did representative La I move up to
pass okay we're ought to pass by
representative long seconded by
representative Schmidt who got there
first do you wish to speak to your
motion uh no all right Schmidt do you
wish to speak to your second I do so so
this is a bill that we had last year
that the uh the committee unanimously
approved um and it got hung up uh
because it was Ved what it was Ved well
that was a hangup because uh the
lobbyist of the Kyo
prors uh pointed out that there was a
defect in the bill the concept was fine
but Bill had a problem and and the the
chiropractors uh opposed it for that
reason um and and the lobbyist spoke
with the governor and the governor
vetoed it but now that defect has been
corrected it's back before us again with
the underlying bill was recognized by
the committee is a is a necessary idea
because especially the fact that people
were having problems and they needed to
have the chiropractor work on their
animal uh and the problem was that
getting the referral from the
chiropractors was very un uh sorry from
the
veterinarians uh was very difficult in
many cases and involved a considerable
delay so here's the client with a an
animal has a problem that the
chiropractor can fix but the referral is
hanging them up for weeks or months at
the time uh and that was not viable so
that's the reason that uh that this bill
came about representative Kelly who was
the sponsor uh you know presented the
case to us last year everybody
recognized that this was uh not an
acceptable
situation but the defect caused the
government Governor to veto it now I've
spoken with a lobbyist who says it's
been corrected and we have a new
governor as well so now we're going to
go at it again and try and correct the
situation with this improved and and
corrected bill so thank you very much
right does anyone else have a comment
question all right seeing none the
motion is ought to pass by
representative long the clerk can call
the role Vice chairman L yes clerk votes
yes representative Bailey I
representative shean yes representative
sers yes representative Roda yes
representative Schmidt yes
representative Davis yes representative
dargy yes representative Howard yes
representative
dver yes representative loan yes and the
chair yes
130 all right the motion passes 13 to Z
is there any objection to
consent seeing none we'll put that one
on consent representative long at your
earliest convenience a committee report
either a hard copy or email
yes all right I believe that's the last
of the bills we have that are ready to
be exact unless somebody has another
one no the other two are still are in
subcommittee that need need some work so
I'll close the public hearing we're
start the executive session the next
public hearing is at
10:45 and for your reading pleasure
committee we have a report on
enforcement on built the history of
building codes and their
enforcement which will be useful for the
next three bills
that's
all
get
I
mean
e
e e
I'm hello it is uh just after 10:45 and
I would like to open the hearing on
House Bill 134 and recognize
representative
Maguire thank you Madame chair members
of the committee Carol Maguire
representing marac District
27 and House Bill 134 is intended to
update the state building code to
incorporate the 2023 version of the
electrical code uh it also includes
amendments approved by the board bu
building code review board through the
time I submitted the bill which was
September
13th and
it's there are people behind behind me
who can explain it a lot better I was
just following orders on this one it's a
request of the building code review
board uh representative McGuire was you
you said the two there were dual
purposes I missed the second one the
first was to update the state electrical
code to the 2023 version what was the
other provision for this bill it adopt
it ratifies amendments approved by the
building code review board through
September
13th the only amendment that I am
positive of that was approved between
the previous ratification date which I
think was in May
May and September is the adoption of
the
uh leak test limit that we passed last
year and told them to
approve other
questions seeing none thank you very
much next we call Steven rort from
ECB good morning Madam chair and
committee members my name is stepen rank
cour I'm a licensed electrician of State
of New Hampshire um I represent the
electrical contractors Business
Association and we're here in favor of
this um this bill it's updating our code
is something that's done every three
years and it went through the process
with the state building code to adopt
any amendments that they felt were
needed to it they had a subcommittee
that went through worked over for over a
year and um we worked together with them
and I think it's uh got all all things
are important to the state and it should
bring us up to the most recent code so I
also want to just take a minute to thank
the chairman of the uh State Building
Code of View Board Phil shman he's done
a lot of work to coordinate these things
for all the Amendments and and really
make this process much better along with
represent of Maguire so that we're not
here in front of you arguing about
amendments we just come to you with a
nice bill that hopefully works so
I appreciate if you would vote for it to
move forward and answer any questions
thank you any questions from the
committee seeing n thank you very
much and next I'll call Philip Sherman
from the building code review board
uh good morning Madam chair members of
the committee it's good to see some old
friends and some new friends here uh
thank you for the invitation today
representative Maguire uh thought it
might be helpful to provide just a
little bit of context as to where this
fits into our overall process for some
of the new members uh but my name is
Philip Sherman I'm the chair of the of
the New Hampshire building code review
board uh and for the record I speak in
favor of this bill so the New Hampshire
state building code consists of eight uh
so-called model codes published by
volunteer
organizations uh seven of which are
published by the International Code
Council the eighth being the electrical
code which is published by the National
Fire Protection Association those model
codes come out on a three-year cycle so
when we talk about the 2023 code we're
coming off of the 2020 model code um
we're not exactly synced with that cycle
yet but after this this round we hope to
become synced where every three years we
update the code which will lag one
published Edition behind the model codes
as required by Statute um so that's the
general context that's why you're only
seeing the electrical code now is their
publication date rides a year behind the
International Code Council seven other
codes the building code the residential
code and so forth so we'll be back with
with the next iteration of those codes
on the next round so uh on October 16th
of last year we forwarded recommended
legislation is required by Statute to
the advisory committee on State Building
and fire codes which ultimately resulted
in this legislation in summary the
building uh the bill would would adopt
the 2023 edition of the national
electorate code there are 19 New
Hampshire amendments and two additional
amendments to the International energy
conservation code that this bill would
ratify the board approved a report on
the 2023 NEC which has been provided uh
to identify the relative cost impact of
significant changes between the 2020
Edition and the 2023 Edition and I want
to pass Steve's thanks only through me
to the four electrical Representatives
on our board who really really really
know where every comma and period is in
that code and they did the heavy lifting
on getting us through to this point a
public hearing was held on the updated
code in the Amendments after which our
board voted unanimously to recommend
this
legislation most of the amendments are
we call them carry forward amendments so
they just ride from addition to addition
although they're reviewed each time
because the same the same issues come up
in each addition of the code there are
three new amendments each each of which
save cost and five previous amendments
were dropped as they were no longer no
longer needed sometimes our amendments
work their way into the code sometimes
sections are combined and one Amendment
becomes two or vice versa
likewise um after we submitted the
recommended legislation the doj
clarified that the amendment to the 2018
ICC on building air testing as required
by uh Senate bills 373 last last of the
last session was effectively already
ratified by the legislature so in fact
it didn't need to be in this process uh
you ratified it or or the general court
ratified it when they adopted that bill
uh but the amendment is there the other
Amendment to the iecc simply takes the
longstanding energy code submitt form
and makes it an amendment rather than a
rule and the reason for that is it needs
to stay in sync with the updated code so
it comes out at the same time the codes
do no real changes to the form it was
just a matter of how we adopt that form
Again by Statute um so that's all I have
to say I thank uh you for your time and
I'm happy to answer any questions you
are there any questions from the
committee members seeing none thank
you is there anybody else who is here to
speak on House Bill
134 seeing none um with that I will
close the public hearing on House Bill
134 so not did we want to go into an
executive session on this one most
likely perfect then I will move over we
will continue in just a moment
okay we'll start an executive session on
House Bill
134 and I'll move on to pass I'll second
Howard moves on second
thank you I have nothing to add
representative Howard uh I think that
this is a pretty Common Sense uh change
to the building code thank you all right
any other comments questions
concerns okay not seeing any the motion
is ought to pass and the clerk can call
the
role Vice chair uh Vice chairman Lon
yes the clerk votes yes
representative Bailey
yes representative Sheen
yes representative sers yes
representative groa yes representative
Schmidt yes representative Davis yes
representative dargy yes representative
Howard yes representative D yes
representative long
yes and the chair yes 13
Z all right the motion passes is there
any objection to
consent okay seeing none we'll put this
on consent the committee is in recess
until
11:30 thanks to very efficient
testimony and
um okay see you then
to
e
e e
hello I would like to open the hearing
on House Bill 428 and invite the prime
sponsor representative ex Alexander to
speak good morning um house committee
executive departments administrations
it's refreshing to see a committee
running on time right now I think a lot
of them are behind including mine so
congratulations thank you for that um
for the record my name is representative
Joe Alexander I'm serving my fourth term
I represent the town of gtown um I also
sit as chairman of the housing committee
um as well as on Judiciary um I am here
to present what I believe is a pretty
straightforward bill that does exactly
what it says in the title it streamlines
State Building Code by making it
consistent across all of our
municipalities currently under state law
municipalities are able to make
amendments to the state code that are
more stringent this causes the
possibility of hundreds of different
codes across the state can you see where
that's an issue um this bill would make
the following codes consistent across
all municipalities um I'm going to read
just four of them but there's like nine
of them on this list the international
building code 2021 International
residential code of 2021 the electrical
code and all amendments that have been
reviewed by the state building go review
board as of May 20 May 10th 2024 and
ratified by this body um last year so um
mainly I propose this because I mean
government aot in um in her inaugural
address indicated that housing is one of
the most important issues facing New
Hampshire but in general this bill would
would take a step in the right direction
by establishing one state code this will
enable businesses residential
developments and Industrial developments
have one code so you don't have to hire
consultants for each Town you're
building in or to figure out what their
amendments to the code are um I mean
there's some ridiculous like local codes
that have occurred um you know so this
consistency will provide better outcomes
by making the process less painful um
for those who wish in businesses and
Residences that wish to invest in our
state so um I will say that um SB 437
passed this body last year
2024 um there's currently no Municipal
amendments right now to the State
Building Code I I believe Phil Sherman
is here you can correct me if I'm wrong
but that's what I we spoke about that in
the hallway um so this is the perfect
time to pass a bill like this because
there's really not a lot of Municipal
amendments yet existing because this is
Val the building code was just updated
to 2021 building code so um with that
I'm happy to take questions there are
other people here experts that can speak
but I I think philosophically it's
incredibly important that we streamline
a lot of these make government more
efficient um you know there's nothing
wrong with the state code AS is the
legislature Dives deep into it um the
building code review board has um
multiple experts on the board that
evaluate the merits of um certain
policies and certain codes so I think I
have confidence that this legislative
branch can can handle um safety aspects
and make sure that you know citizens are
safe and secure um but while also making
it easy for people to live in live and
renovate their property the way they see
fit so um with that I'm happy to answer
questions thank you other uh okay
representative long uh do you have
examples of those local amendments to
building codes that were uh extreme or
inappropriate in your opinion um there's
some that I philosop thank you for the
question representative I mean there's
some that I philosophically believe with
I think um you know more stringent local
energy codes I think would be a good
example of that you know um for instance
a town that would require um a a
different type of window for Energy
Efficiency or things like that I think
um adds more of a layer than what's
currently needed and I think based on
the philosophical makeup of a town they
may you know have a more stringent
energy code to you know combat climate
change or something like that so I just
want to make sure it's consistent across
you know the entire
state representative groda thank you um
representative Alexandria I just want to
make it clear that this wouldn't prevent
individuals who wanted to have an
updated version of anything that was in
the um more recent codes that are not
adopted by the state able to do so
that's that's a great question um this
is the this is the floor right like you
know if you want to build the most
energy efficient property um you know to
to to reduce your energy costs like you
are more than welcome to do that um the
state building code is the code it's the
it's the floor um that's required to to
build up to and then anything additional
you're still allowed to to build on so
it it maintains private property rights
uh thank you representative Alexander um
does this also go to affordability
because if somebody is being forced to
adopt say windows that aren't commonly
used in the state would that be a more
expensive component that leads to access
to housing oh absolutely huge and and
you know I've spoken to the home
builders who um are in support of this
legislation that say basically like you
know having to hire consultants for each
project depending on what town you live
in is an onerous thing so that increased
cost there but not on top of that you
have like you know if there are more
requirements more often than not they're
more expensive but you know they could
be less expensive but um for my
experience they' be more so that's a
great question and I wholeheartedly
agree thank you representative
ree hi um my question has to do with
local conditions so I live in Hampton
and I believe if I'm not mistaken that
our town actually requires an extra foot
of freeboard would this this bill
prevent us and in fact roll back that
requirement if I'm correct um so thank
you for your question representative it
would prevent it I do not believe it
would roll back because the way the code
is written now it's the it is the
building code there haven't been
Municipal
amendments to that code recently I I'll
let Phil Phil Sherman clarify that but
um yes this bill would prevent something
like that thank you you're
welcome seeing no further questions
thank you very much
representative uh next I'll call call
Margaret Burns to speak from the New
Hampshire Municipal Association
good morning I'm Margaret Burns
representing the New Hampshire Municipal
Association we are here this morning in
opposition to House Bill 428 House Bill
428 would take away established local
authority to adopt local codes which has
been established in state law for many
years additionally this bill comes on
the heels of legislation that was passed
just last year that would have made
pretty serious changes that did make
pretty serious changes to the way in
which local building codes are
enforcable so just last year this
legislature through I believe Senate
Bill 437 passed some substantial changes
that required in part uh municipalities
send their local building code
amendments to the State Building Code
review board and in order if they didn't
do that the codes would become
unenforceable so we've just recently had
a quite substantial change in the way
that these codes become enforcable after
after adoption and I would ask the
committee to consider letting the
legislation from last year play out
before we go ahead and remove entirely
local authority to adopt local building
codes I would also note that I know
you're going to hear this morning from
Phil Sherman I believe you're also going
to hear this morning from a
representative from the New Hampshire
building um building officials
Association if this bill is going to
move forward those two stakeholders do
have suggestions about amendments that
would be need to make the bill workable
and I would urge the committee to also
listen to those suggestions to make the
bill workable if the bill will be moving
forward thank you so much for your time
thank you question uh representative
long so I'm not really familiar with the
process of how uh municipalities make
amendments to the building code uh when
that's done is that something that's
voted on by the voters or is it done by
the politicians in the town great
question so they are voted on by the
local legislative body and in the
majority of our municipalities the local
legislative body is in fact the town
meeting so it is the voters just like
they would also be the ones to adopt
local zoning amendments in the
municipalities where the legislative
body is the city council the couple of
towns where the legislative body is the
Town Council and the two cities where
the legislative body is the board of
alderman they would be the body to adopt
those codes locally
other questions from the committee
seeing none thank you very much next
I'll call Phil
Sherman Madame chair members of the
committee my name is Philip Sherman and
I speak as the chair of the building
code review board uh and I'm in favor of
this bill only if amended uh the
building code review board itself does
not take a position on this bill at this
time only due to our meeting sequence
and not having had the language at our
last meeting uh but it propos the bill
proposes to eliminate the current
authorization from municipalities to
amend the State Building Code I think I
heard a question about adopting later
additions of the model codes that are
within the State Building Code that was
prohibited by legislation last year
um we do find however that if this bill
moov moves forward it's important to
allow for certain administrative
amendments related to statutory
Authority and to allow for the various
ways that the code is implemented in the
various municipalities large cities
operate differently than small
towns um we also believe that for the
issues involved this is a good time to
move some of the building code related
sections now in the land use and City
Grant of power chapters into
155a which is what the the proposed Bill
HP 244 is trying to do this afternoon
anyway um so this corrects some
conflicting terminology and allows us to
fix a cross reference error with the
current statutes and so forth um it also
would maintain through an amendment this
is the current uh building code
Amendment confirmation process for the
now permitted administrative amendments
just to make sure they stay on track
so while we have a significant Amendment
sort of uh drafted out it's not ready
for prime time yet there's some loose
ends that need to be resolved the State
Fire Marshall has some concerns with how
it's written drafted at this point and
that's why we're not prepared to submit
it today and we would therefore submit
moving this to a subcommittee for a
quick turnaround and I thank you for
your consideration happy to answer any
questions thank you are questions from
the committee representative
Schmidt I thank thank mam chair good
morning Phil uh so did I understand you
correctly to say you support 428 local
only if
amended my support will be limited to my
personal view not the board's view but
uh I can safely say that the board would
agree that if it moves forward uh it
needs amendments or we're going to have
a real mess in terms of how things are
enforced out in the field thank you very
much any other questions from the
committee seeing none thank you very
much thank you uh next I'll call I
believe this is Philip jazik I apologize
if I mispel misstated
that good afternoon Madam chair uh my
name is Philip jzac I'm the
communications director for the New
Hampshire Home Builders Association um
we are very much in favor of this bill
um the biggest one of the things that we
hear a lot from our Builders especially
our smaller Builders one two three man
shop
is that it's very difficult for them to
navigate the changes across
municipalities and this would allow them
that consistency and simplicity to go
forward uh or excuse me going
forward and the uh the consistency as
well as mentioned by representative
Alexander would allow allow our Builders
to keep cost down and make housing more
attainable for our consumers um it's
also important to know I believe it was
asked and answered but this would not
prevent anybody from doing anything we
just at the New Hampshire Home Builders
we want our consumers to decide what
they want for a house not be forced into
anything you questions from the
committee representative
scitec Mr jasc you heard uh Mr Sherman
how do you feel about the tone of his
amendments so I uh I have not
investigated that personally I would
have to go back to uh go back and and
look into that
I I'm not going to give you a guess
right now I would like to give you a
concrete
answer followup if there is a
subcommittee will somebody from the uh
building contractors be there we would
absolutely like to be there if you if we
are asked to be there we will be there
representative Dev thank you do you have
examples of specific towns that have
higher standards now and how it is
impacting affordable housing or
access yes so in currently all I have
right now is is information and stories
and um anecdotal evidence from my
Builders um I did go in and try to
research this on my own the the towns in
which I did research it was very
difficult to find specific amendments
that were made to the code um as they
were not available online um so I would
have to do more research on that to give
you a comprehensive list thank you thank
you representative
Schmidt thank you Madam chair so uh CH
question of the chair first is it going
to subcommittee the bill yes it will it
will be thank you uh now my question for
this gentleman so um you're new to me
could you spell your last name for me
please jzac J
A
okay thank you you and um I have a
question for you as well when you look
at different Regional and Geographic
differences are Builders looking at
things like a Sea Coast climate and
already making adaptations that are
appropriate to that environment like
potentially the freeboard whether or not
it's in code yes so the the state
building code is based off of the iecc
international code which takes into
account all the different climate zones
on the entire planet so um the vast
majority of instances we would run into
in this stay already covered by the code
thank you representative scitec you you
said something that uh
that's really not part of this but I'd
like to hear people for building
contractors or speak to this issue you
couldn't find things online how
transparent are building codes town to
toown uh that's tough for me to answer
right now I did not look at all 234
municipalities thank you uh
representative log uh just a followup to
that question are the building codes the
municipal amendments to it required to
be available in writing in some
format uh that I am not sure of I
apologize any other questions from the
committee seeing none thank you very
much you and next I'll call natch Grace
from
Bia thank you n Grace the business and
industry Association uh we are the
state's uh Statewide Chamber of Commerce
uh we support this legislation U before
anyone asks me uh we would be supportive
of any friendly amendments to uh make
sure that everything works uh and is and
is uh works well uh I think as Mr
Sherman alluded to uh within the
statutes there has been
historically a mixing of things between
the building code and the zoning the
zoning statutes um so legislation you'll
hear later today would attempt to
separate out those um but one of the
problems with the the mixing is
obviously you have different authorities
trying to do different things um so some
clarity may be uh necessary I've not yet
seen his Amendment um but I'm happy to
work with that uh work with him or
anyone on any such
amendments um just to not belabor any
points but to give you a little bit of
History here uh the Statewide building
code was initially adopted uh in the
early
2000s in response uh to the fact that we
are a small state and having 234
different building codes uh made it very
difficult for developers to know on a
Town Bytown basis um where they would
what they would have to build to as a
standard now I want to be clear that the
building code is not about what can be
built in a certain location but how it's
built um so it's not about whether or
not this is a house or gas station uh or
anything else it's about okay if this is
is going to be a house how are you going
to build this um realistically uh
looking at the climate zones in New
Hampshire that Mr JC uh referenced at
the international building code level
there aren't too many differences um
there are some obviously with the SE
Coast some uh obviously in the South
versus Coos County you're seeing some
differences in terms of what's what's
required but uh not not significant and
that's mainly because we are a small
state um over time the building code
after initial adoption in the early
2000s was adopted periodically updated
periodically by the state
legislature um back in I believe it was
about 2017 to 2019 the legislature
started uh the process of of creating a
very clear process where now every three
years essentially the state um the State
Building officials they come forward uh
with an update uh representative McGuire
has been the prime sponsor of that
update uh for the past several sessions
um so they look at the updated uh
International building codes which come
out every 3 years make suggestions to
tailor those to New Hampshire propose
those to the legislature and then if all
goes smoothly those go through with some
changes um so we have a very clear
process now um and so what that does is
it updates the codes across the state uh
every three years so some of that prior
legislation that was referenced um they
it did update both definitions as well
as codes so one of the problems that
would be addressed uh kind of
additionally by a one state one code
model is that a number of municipalities
over time adopted amendments that are
now out of date um technically because
definitions have been updated they
should go through the update process and
under existing law they would have to
provide that to the State Building Code
uh review board um and I believe some
have provided or attempted to provided
updates but none of those have been
approved yet and therefore not in effect
but it may be the case that at the local
levels was referenced by representative
rise some municipalities are attempting
to enforce updates that are not yet
actually in effect because they haven't
gone through that uh existing
legislative process um but it may be the
case at one point in time they did have
those as mandates um I don't have any
good examples for you of um those
changes that would be significantly
affected uh the one that I know of that
comes to mind is naswa has a very
specific uh spr
um happy to take any questions the
committee may have any questions from
the
committee representative Schmidt thank
you madam chair so you've heard that
we're going to have a sub committee um
there's several questions been raised by
Representatives uh that clearly need to
be further investigated and and fleshed
out and so forth so you intend to
participate because we I think we need
your input if I'm available I'd be happy
to participate very good thank
you any other questions from the
committee seeing none thank you very
much for your testimony and I would like
to call Representative Maguire
thank you Madame chair members of the
committee
I'm just res just responding to the
questions about local amendments the
situation is that last year we
completely changed the process we also
updated this overall State Building Code
from the 21 ver to to the uh 19
2021 version all over so any
existing um local amendments that
applied to the previous version were
automatically invalidated by that
process some of them were carried for
would be able to be carried forward and
I believe at least one municipality has
done so they had a specific one it they
they brought it to the building code
review board and it was approved
um and I would confirm that the a large
problem we have had in the past is that
Municipal amendments were not formally
adopted they were sometimes informally
adopted or informally enforced by the
building inspectors which is very
difficult to keep uniform and
fair so
um that's why we updated the process to
require amendments to be formally
approved by the town so that if a town
does want something specific they can
approve it and and have that would also
require that all local amendments are
posted on the State Building Code Review
Board website so that people can know
what's going on that in the past knowing
what communities had which amend M ments
if any was extremely difficult so the
current process as of six months ago is
that the
towns suggested a change approve them by
their legislative body and submit them
to the State Building Code review board
to ensure that they are compatible with
the state building code and the
municipal Authority which in most cases
means is more stringent than the basic
State Building Code
uh M Mr Sherman can tell you more
accurately than I can how many
municipalities are in the process of
approving them but I did hear that at
least one town did submit an amendment
properly
authorized and it has been approved so
uh it is a very new process so people
are not
always um familiar with it
I did work a bit with the municipal
Association to help train towns and
building inspectors about the new
process because it is different than
what it had been but um so it is a
change not everybody's up to it but the
intent is to make building code
amendments be more transparent and more
available and hopefully more uniform
across the state oh thank you
representative log uh on the subject of
building inspectors sort of doing their
own thing how much ambiguity is there in
the State Building Code that would allow
someone to sort of make up their own
interpretation of it I am not an expert
but I've read portions of the building
code in many cases there are two
different op two or three different
options of acceptable ways to do do
something it is I've heard cases where
the building inspector
said do it this way there are
also um verbal instructions that are not
incompatible with the building code but
they're uh
different and I have also anecdotally
heard of building inspectors saying well
that's how we do it here without any
formal approval or adoption of that
change and I I will reiterate that
the the Builder or the owner is
perfectly free to adopt more stringent
requirements than the State Building
Code uh I built my house in 2008 and n
and it is much more energy efficient
than the building codes at the time
required because I was my husband and I
were willing to invest the money to do
so
um and that was our option
and it's it's worked out very well for
us the as was stated the state building
code is a floor it's not a
ceiling representative
gr so my understanding um representative
Maguire is that
this amend this bill would set the floor
for the state and if and if
municipalities wanted to amend the code
there's a process for them to do so but
it sort of gets everybody on the same no
no no represent BR this bill would say
the town cannot make changes technical
changes to the State Building Code Mr
Sherman was saying that well you need to
have a a better definition of the
enforcement process which but it's an
administrative change not a uh technical
change the the current status is the
towns can adopt changes to the State
Building code this bill would remove
that
Authority follow up well thank you but
in the current the current rule the
current law says that they can amend it
but it they have to apply to there's an
approval process for those so that this
bill removes all that yes it removes the
entire Municipal amendment
process and the amendment that is being
contemplated is purely for you know how
we
implement the inspections that are still
required thank you thank you any other
questions from the committee saying none
thank you very much is there anybody
else here to speak on this bill seeing
none I will close the hearing on House
Bill 428 and we will be in recess until
1:15 thank you make
oh did she close the hearing Yes except
for that one running out you're like
are you on the
subcommittee you
know I'll look over you when somebody's
testifying
e
e e
where did you get
that wife former speaker
s
e
e e
uh thank you and welcome back I will
open the hearing on house Bill
244 and uh welcome representative
Maguire good afternoon Madame chair
members of the committee Carol Maguire
of marac District
27 and House Bill 244 is a request of
the building code review
board and it is intended to be a
recodification and
consolidation of the enforcement of the
building and fire cats to take it out of
the random places it's currently
scattered through uh Municipal Authority
City Authority planning board authority
zoning board of
appeals take it out of all those places
and consolidate it
under uh 155 which is the State Building
Code 155a whatever and
um it is intended not to have any policy
changes but with a bill this size it's
always possible that there are some
inadvertent
uh
misrepresentations or mis references and
so um I have planned all along that this
go to subcommittee for examination by
the subcommittee and any other
interested parties U if you have any
general questions I'll try to answer
them
are there any questions from the members
of the committee representative salers
yeah thank you um my question is the the
idea of this is just to consolidate like
you said to the point that everything is
in one spot right yes and is it taking
the authority away from the
municipalities as well no it is not
taking away any authority of the
municipalities to enforce the fire fire
or building codes in their
municipality should they choose to do so
representative Gera thank you um
represent Maguire just want confirmation
from you that there's no change in
policy as a result of these changes it
there is no change of policy intended by
this bill I cannot guarantee that there
isn't one tucked away someplace which is
why it's going to
subcommittee any no saying no other
questions thank you very much um next
I'll call Philip
Sherman thank you madam chair members of
the committee for the record my name is
Philip Sherman I speak as the chair of
the building code review board and I'm
in favor of this bill um as confirmed by
multiple people involved in the
enforcement of the building code there
is time extensive at times extensive
confusion about how Implement
implementation of the building code
crosses paths with zoning and other land
use statutes much of this confusion
comes from sections that continue from a
time before the state adopted a
Statewide code and municipalities own
the whole thing if they enforced a
building code through 2024 a task force
of the bcrb made an attempt to identify
the land use sections related to
building codes Building Code Enforcement
and building code code appeals and find
a home for those in
155a our intent as was previously stated
was that no permissions or no
responsibilities would change this would
only be an editorial process as you
heard this morning we recommend that
certain portions of the land use
chapters be moved to 155a by HP 428
we'll deal with that outside of this
room as part of those changes this is a
complicated exercise on three front from
our perspective first the related
sections are splattered throughout the
land use sections they've just grown up
over time some need to be moved some
need to be copied so there are
Provisions in there that apply to both
zoning and building code we need to
leave them in both places second the
land use provisions for appeals
particularly have evolved to become a
highly complex and sometimes expensive
process lawyers and notifications and a
bunch of those kinds of of and this may
not be required for at least all
building code appeals so we need to get
many eyes on this to see if something of
the somewhat onerous Provisions really
need to be carried over or whether they
can be skinny down for building code
purposes and lastly as you can predict
this is trying to edit a move somewhat
moving ship uh 428 proposes to amend the
process as does at least one other Bill
currently in play we do think however
that the the issues addressed in 428 are
discreet enough to permit those to be
moved but trying to trying to move this
stuff at the same time other things are
changing those same issues needs a lot
of coordination so for this reason we
would support moving this bill to a
subcommittee with enough time allowed uh
to deal with these issues and I'm happy
to answer any
questions thank you any questions from
the
committee seeing none thank you very
much oh sorry I did not see you there
Representative schmi no problem I didn't
put I put my hand up just as you turned
away so not not your fault at all so uh
the question I have is uh this is
certainly the kind of thing that oplc
sorry not oplc OLS does uh when they uh
when they have finished drafting a bill
they have two uh other drafters one
reads one uh reads out loud
um and that's to see that they don't
have typos and that type of thing um is
this something that we that we should
also ask them to look at because as
drafters they can see has the language
changed in any way which is the warning
that we've heard from both of both you
and chairman
McGuire I think obviously that's a
necessary step what I what I don't know
and others can advise us us and
certainly the the subcommittee can
figure out is when that ought to happen
our proposal is that some of the
language ought to change because we've
carried so much land
use legal context over to the building
code because all we did was copy it we
didn't try and judge it we just copied
it over right 25 pages of stuff that can
probably be significantly reduced I
think we'll we'll we'll see now whether
uh OS ought to review it before that or
after that or or how that works I'll
leave for others but yeah I don't think
if I might say impr preference to
another question uh that I don't think
that they would have done that if they
were instructed to consolidate and
transfer that's what they would have
done uh but but you uh will be guiding
Us in Your Capacity as uh enforcer or or
consultant if you will on all these
codes uh you're recommending the sub
committee I presume you're going to
participate vigorously and make
suggestions along the lines that you
think things should be slimmed down yes
and we've also gotten uh some support
from the municipal Association who have
people who really understand these
issues particularly on the land use side
more than we do because that's not our
our remit um and can help thank you I
think all of that is helpful to know
thank you thank you um seeing no other
questions from from the committee thank
you very much and next I'll call philli
jazik jik I'll get it right the more I
see
you thank you again Madam chair uh
Philip jayac Comm uh director of
communications for the New Hampshire
homeb Builder Association I don't have a
whole lot more to add after uh chairman
Sherman's testimony we just we we looked
at it and we support anything that you
know consolidating simplifying putting
things in one place so thank you any
questions from the
committee seeing none thank you we
appreciate
that is there anybody else who would
like to speak on House Bill 244
today seeing none I will close the
hearing on 244 and as stated this will
be going to a
subcommittee and uh we will recess until
2 o'clock when we will hear our next
vill
thank
you
e
e e
girl
all right good afternoon welcome back
I'm opening the hearing on House Bill 96
and I call Representative
[Music]
Thomas thank you m Madam chair and
members of the committee for the record
my name is Wendy Thomas and I represent
the town of marac I'm here to discuss
House Bill 96 which would require New
Hampshire Builders to use the 2021
Energy building codes or a simp similar
code that achieves equivalent or greater
Energy
savings so adopting the 2021 codes could
spur economic growth in the following
ways it promotes green construction
industry the demand for sustainable and
energy efficient buildings could attract
new businesses and talent to New
Hampshire's con construction industry
especially with an increasing National
focus on Green Building practices job
creation it the Imp implementation of
the upd updated codes requires
additional training for contractors
inspectors And Trades
people buildings that meet higher
standards of safety and Energy
Efficiency are often see increased
property
value homeowners who invest in energy
efficient homes could see a return on
investment and these improvements could
make New Hampshire a more attractive
place for businesses and new residents
these economic benefits would not only
support the construction industry but
also provide a boost to New Hampshire's
local economy as a whole particularly if
the state Embraces the growing trend of
sustainable and resilient building while
it's true that short-term construction
costs may rise leading to higher housing
prices and potential challenges for
low-income families the adoption of the
2021 building codes could help mitigate
some of the state's housing challenges
by reducing long-term costs the the
improved efficiency of new homes could
make them more affordable able to
maintain overtime even if initial
construction prices
rise and with climate change likely
exacerbating housing housing
challenges stronger more resilient
buildings can reduce future costs
related to repairs insurance and
infrastructure thus keeping housing
costs more stable in the long run
additionally higher property value for
energy efficient homes could encourage
developers to build more especially in
growing Urban and Suburban areas helping
to address the ongoing housing shortage
over time many other states have already
adopted uh or are in the process of
adopting newer energy codes and the New
Hampshire risk and New Hampshire risks
sorry being left behind if it delays the
transition by aligning with national
standards New Hampshire would maintain
competitiveness and improve
marketability this alignment would also
ensure that New Hampshire benefits from
The Innovation and progress happening in
the building building industry at a
national level which could further
enhance the state's reputation as a
forward-thinking resilient place to live
and work on balance however adopting the
2021 building codes in New Hampshire by
2025 without further delay appears to
yield better long-term results for the
people of this of the state despite
upfront challenges while there are valid
concerns regarding implementation costs
and the impact on housing affordability
the overall benefits in terms of of
safety sustainability economic growth
and Energy Efficiency seem to outweigh
the potential
drawbacks the Energy Efficiency
improvements mandated by the 2021 codes
will bring sufficient long-term benefits
to homeowners businesses and States as a
whole by lowering utility bills and
providing economic resilience over time
the initial construction cost increases
could be offset by these ongoing savings
additionally with more efficient
building New Hampshire can better manage
Rising energy demand and reduce its
carbon footprint which is crital
critical for
sustainability New Hampshire is
increasingly exposed to extreme weather
events including winter storms flooding
and the effects of climate change uh
which include intense rainfall Coastal
erosion and high winds the 2021 codes
improve the resilience of buildings by
addressing these these issues while
these improvements come with upfront
cost they will likely reduce the need
for extensive repairs or rebuilding
after storms which can make which can be
more expensive than proactive investment
in re in resilience additionally as
climate change accelerates these
upgrades will protect lives and property
reducing the risk of economic loss from
natural
disasters while the concerns about
increased costs potential slow adoption
and the impact on housing afford
affordability are valid the long-term
benefits of adopting the 2020 21
building codes especially in terms of
safety Energy Efficiency and climate
resilience are likely to outweigh the
costs the investment in stronger more
sustainable and energy efficient
buildings will not only help protect
residents and property but will also
possession position New Hampshire for
future economic growth and environmental
sustainability by adopting the new codes
without further delay New Hampshire will
benefit from a safer more resilient and
economically prosperous future while
still addressing the immediate
challenges through phased implementation
and support measures for buildings
Builders and homeowners uh thank you and
I actually have a handout uh that comes
from uh Governor Shaheen's office that
identifies funding that could be related
to this adopting these codes and I'll
Governor Shaheen's Governor Shaheen so
it's um 20 years Governor geeez I'm
sorry it's been a really really long day
um Senator Shaheen that would be Senator
thank than you that may be more
timely sorry about that all right thank
you and U I'm I'll all right are there
any questions from the
committee represent
sers represent
long you may not be the best person to
ask about this um so for anyone else who
testifying I would like to hear this
answer if representative Thomas is not
able to answer it um um do you have a an
estimate of what the additional upfront
costs are of building a house uh if the
new energy code is adopted and what the
annual Energy savings
are those do have estimates from what I
understand those estimates may not be as
reliable as as people think they are and
I am not the best person to answer that
we have other people who should provide
more information
yes you're on the list to answer that
question thank
you representative L uh thank you madam
chair and thank you representative for
bringing this to us um you spoke about
some pretty good Market opportunities
where people will make more money
building these homes I'm just curious if
you have anything that would prevent
that from happening
today well no we're still building in
New Hampshire um it's just that we're
building buildings that are not as
potentially as res resilient as they
could be so we're building buildings
today that may not have as good a resale
value had we been doing it using these
codes that's all right follow up uh so
you're saying that right now people are
limited and cannot adopt these um these
new
technologies or you simp or are you
saying they simply aren't being forced
to adopt these Technologies because it
was my understanding that you can build
a passive house or anything that is
highly energy efficient and that's a
choice that can be made there is a
choice right now it's not mandated I
think this is looking for a mandate I
mean what you're saying is true a friend
of mine just sold our house and and is
building a net zero house in
Massachusetts I mean there are some
builders that will do that but it's not
across the board thank you
okay salers thank you madam chair so one
question I have is
um the difference between 2018 21 do you
know what those changes are I'm just
trying to get an idea of what the
Builder has to put in to make the
difference I am quite certain the people
that will testify behind me will be able
to answer that
question anyone
else all right thank you very much and
we'll start with some of the people that
know about it Mr Sherman
Madam chair members of the committee for
the record my name is Philip Sherman
chair of the building code review board
the bcrb at this time takes no position
on this bill but would ask uh the
sponsor not withstanding uh that it be
amended to refer to the 2024 edition of
the international energy conservation
code AS required by Statute we're
entering into our review of the 2024
code expected to be completed by June
and it only makes sense that we all look
at the same document uh at that point
I'll happy to answer any
questions okay representative Howard uh
thank you for taking my question so are
there any potential glitches uh that
occurred in the 2021 codes as and and
could be the reason why we didn't adopt
them thank
you I I guess I don't understand the
question uh so obviously we kind of have
a three-year lag in adopting our uh
building codes and in 2021 we did or in
2024 we did not adoped the 2021 building
codes uh it's kind of the question I I
was not on the committee I didn't know
necessarily if you knew uh what
potential glitches were and why we did
not adopt yeah just to if I may correct
one thing we adopted the 2021 codes
except for the energy code which we held
back at the 18 code uh that was after an
extensive uh amount of committee work on
on our part board's part uh with much
input from outside um and the vote at
that time was N9 to4 to stay on the 18
code uh much of it I think came down to
cost um and others can explain the
details of that um my understanding is
that the 2024 code uh corrects some of
the issues that people found with the
2021 code but that's just uh what I'm
hearing I don't have facts to back that
up represent thank you U Mr Sherman from
a practicality standpoint is it better
that we adopt building codes that are of
the same
year so that the energy code and the
building codes should go hand inand as
opposed to accepting one that's three
years behind the
other I'll speak only for myself because
I know that there are people who may
disagree with this there are some places
where those codes interact in a in a
significant way for instance if if a
code requires a mechanical system then
the Mechanical Code might refer to how
to how to put that together so we need
to keep track of that stuff um I don't
think it's been terribly difficult or at
least I haven't heard of major problems
uh with the implementation of these
codes to this point but again that's
only a few months now
so thank you represent sellers thank you
madam chair so it makes sense bringing
in the latest code I get that but are
you asking them to for the amendment to
change it to the latest
code before the latest code has actually
been
approved no I let me let me be sure to
clarify we're taking no position on the
bill itself whether it's a good idea or
a bad idea what we would ask is that it
be amended to to talk about the 2024
code if you're going to to talk about a
code just so we're not going in opposite
directions here follow up thank you so
has the 2024 code been approved though
no it's been published it was published
last May so it's been out on the street
for people to read our board by Statute
is given the timing of when we're
supposed to review these codes is just
starting our review now thank you which
will end in June presumably that's and
that's the full Suite of 20 24 codes not
just the energy code that's right yeah
okay representative Schmid thank you
madam
chair so the the bill is premised on the
idea that a greater degree of efficiency
and a
whole gamut of areas um I don't have to
speak to you about what they are because
that's your that's your area of
expertise but other are there not
studies out there I don't think the bcrb
is probably doing that but are there
studies of it out there that you're
aware of that speak to the idea of the E
efficiency because I don't think that U
representative uh has you know come up
with this whole concept on her own um
because it requires a lot of expertise
that uh that uh the economy looks at all
the time right what is the most
efficient way to do this and that's the
basis of selling X Y and Z to to improve
your house in any one of a number of
different ways so are you aware of
studies that that validate the the
underlying premise of uh of Wendy's um
of her this is that underlies this bill
and I'm grasping pretty wide I
understand but this is an area you're
probably fishing into some
degree it's an area that our board is
fishing in to some degree um I'm not an
expert on the energy code I know just
enough to get into trouble um my charge
mostly is to try and manage the process
so we have a committee of our board
members five I think uh who are entering
the the the period of reviewing that at
the same time they will go back and look
at the report that was generated last
year when they when they analyzed the
2021 code I'm sorry yeah whenever that
was two years ago um so they've got to
look at two two jumps of this thing if
we go to
2024 if we only go to
2021 um we have no charge to go back and
relook at that that report is is on the
website it's publicly available um
and we'll just do what the legislature
says you know if if that's a
decision thank you other questions
representative Howard so thank you for
taking my question uh since there's a
threee since we usually look at uh
adopting these codes in a three-year lag
would it be okay to potentially look at
the 2021 codes this year and then in
2027 when we approach uh the time when
we look at uh adopting all of the 2024
codes uh would that be
acceptable be acceptable to somebody um
let me if I might just give a little bit
of history there was a delay in adopting
the 2015 codes um when they got adopted
we then worked on the 2018 codes which I
think happened slightly into Co so we've
had a lot of sand in the gears if you
will on getting on to an orderly
sequence the decision of the board and
it was reviewed with the advisory
committee at one point was that we would
spend two years on the 2018 codes which
we did and then two years on the 2021
codes which we're in the middle of now
and then once we get to the 2024 code
was the time to go on to an orderly
three-year hopefully adoption sequence
which would still leave us a a cycle
behind the published codes which is
where the legislature wants us but it
would then get onto a much more
predictable
thing if everything goes well um so
certainly codes can be moved down the
road but but it moves us away you know
farther down the road to get to this
three-year cycle which seems to be
desired by a lot of people it's to get
onto something more predictable yes I
will mention that the the history was
that we don't want to who adopt any of
the codes immediately after their
publication because there are
generally what one might call typos and
and mistakes that the early adopters are
very nicely finding for us and so we can
not Implement those sections a two or
adopting them two couple of years after
they're out gives time to flush out
these uh little
mistakes okay yes
so I think one of the issues that this
committee has been wrestling with are
the the benefits of these codes of the
energy code in light of the potential
increase in costs since we've adopted
the
2018 energy
codes to whom should we
look
for a review of the benefits that's that
people have well that the construction
industry and their customers have
benefited from like we we adopted these
codes I remember when we did that it was
quite
controversial so well not controversial
but it was a lot there were a lot of
teeth nashing you know we all we made
the decision to do it so what benefit
have we
seen as a state from home build whose
houses include those code
changes let me be sure I understand your
question of the benefits of stay of
having stayed on the 18 code there are
others here who can answer that question
right okay I excuse followup follow up
the benefits
of yes of adopting those 2018 energy
code and I thought of another question I
think I think we did that in the
in TW in 20 21 21 I believe 21 yes and
uh and in 24 we declined to go to the uh
code so the home builder should have
information from their point of view I'm
not sure who else would be
tracking uh the benefits to the owners
of homes built to that code
um follow up
and do you
recall um did we adopt only part of the
code is it possible that when we review
these codes we find that we want to
adopt some of them and not others is
that possible to do that or do we have
to adopt them in in their
entity well by not adopting the 2021
energy code two years ago we we've done
what you said right we've broken that
package um the energy code itself for
those of you who have not been into it
consists of two codes one for
residential buildings up to three
stories the other for sort of everything
else larger residential and all the the
span of commercial other than some
fairly small commercial entities so
there was a proposal by one
representative last year that perhaps we
would split the two parts of the energy
code uh it's certainly doable but I
think some of the building officials
here and maybe the designers will
comment on the difficulty and having to
try and remember which book you're in
for what what project and what part of
what project um I've not seen that done
in any other jurisdiction I can't say it
hasn't been done I just haven't seen it
um but it was a proposal last year and I
will say that last year we did adopt one
specific element of the 21 code which
was the air change
requirement U that was was specifically
adopted as an amendment to the 18
code representative
sellers thank you so would it be your
board that could actually give us a list
of differences from 18 to 24 so we know
what the changes are yeah that's one of
the things we're grappling with right
now is how to present that um there are
lists there's already a list of 18 to 21
and then that needs to be melded some
somehow from 21 to 24 just for our
purposes which then goes to the report
that comes to you folks
yeah all right representative L thank
you madam chair um just to make sure
that I understand this whole process
normally you're reviewing them and then
giving us the input before we look to
make a change in the law and this would
be changing the process our our charge
involves recommending leg legislation
yeah nothing we do goes anywhere until
it comes here and on from here there a
followup this would sort of be putting
the cart before the horse to tell you to
adopt the 24 before you've had a chance
to do that review or at least changing
the normal order well no it it tells
this is tells them to adopt the 21 code
which they have already reviewed and
have the um the changes and the the
committee vote not to adopt okay thank
you if that's if that's correct
yes I
[Laughter]
think yes it it it impacts the normal
order of things which is we do the
review then it comes here for your
review and approval or
denial and then to the Governor from
there so other
questions all right thank you very much
you're
welcome all
right yes representative schi sorry
thank you is this going to
subcommittee uh
I think
so
okay and we have always had help from
these people uh Matt
Mayberry good
afternoon my name is Matt Mayberry I'm
the CEO of the New Hampshire
homebuilders Association
we represent the 27,000 people in New
Hampshire your constituents that work in
the Residential Building
Trades we cannot find the words to come
out more strongly
against this
bill and I can tell you why we've had
this conversation before so it's kind of
like deja vu all over
again the cost of the 21 energy code and
I'm going to back up quick
second the last two speakers kind of
convoluted things
so let's open the drapes and make it
really
clear we supported and adopted as a
state and the New Hampshire homebuilders
supported it the 2021 building
codes that's law that's what my folks
are building right
now the energy codes which are being
very cleverly weaved into building codes
the energy
codes we worked with you
folks and passed the 2018 energy
codes for real simple reasons $76
million of consumer housing debt shoved
down the throats of home
buyers that's based upon the
4,520 correction
4,512 building permits that pulled in
23 at an average cost and I was going to
leave her name out of it but since
representative Thomas brought forward
Senator
Shaheen Senator Shaheen states that to
upgrade to the 21 energy code cost
$177,000 that's low but let's use her
numbers that's $76 million of Consumer
Debt on your
constituents most people can't write a
check for $17
,000 so the roll into their
mortgage
6.5% 30-year fixed that comes out to be
over $200
million of Consumer Debt for the next 30
years on that same program on WMUR with
Adam Sexton he asked her what's the
annual
payback on these
upgrades and she looked right at him and
said $500 a
year I do not go to
college but I don't need a degree from
Harvard to do the simple math you will
never live to see your
payback your grandchildren won't live to
see that
payback there was a
conversation about well just you know
amend the bill to do the 24 energy
codes please don't do that we here
talking about the 21 energy codes don't
shove please the 2024 energy codes down
our throats let us go through the
process let's talk about that separately
because if we did the math and I did
beforehand from the National Association
of home builders if we were to jump from
the
18 energy code to the 24 energy code we
have it as
$31,000 that's 100 that just shy of 140
million of Consumer
Debt let's be super conservative let's
cut it in
half that's
$15,500 that's $69 million of Consumer
Debt the largest tax
increase placed upon the home buyers of
the grant
state that comes out at the end of a
30-year mortgage to $182
million of consumer debt this is the
green energy
tax make no
mistake this is a
mandate the reason why we go through the
process of reviewing these things and
then coming to you asking you to adopt
say the 24 energy
code and the reason why there's a
three-year lag is we're very sensitive
to the unintended
consequences and the unintended cost
that's why we do have a three-year
lag that's why we said we can
build the 2021 building codes no problem
we'll do that we'll do our
part but if we want with the 2021 energy
code folks you're going to make
attainable housing just a nice idea for
someone from Cambridge to come up and
buy a house with
Rank and file people living in New
Hampshire can't afford it I was at the
housing committee yesterday testing on
three bills and we heard over 30 people
testifying how they can't afford to live
in New
Hampshire why in the
world would we strap on another $20,000
on top of a house that folks already
can't afford why would we do
that it's pretty simple
so um we have a sample of what the 24
code will look like because one of the
questions was what does 18 to 24 look
like to repair the air leaks about
$3,000 to go to a ground Source heat
pump just shy
$22,000 to upgrade air conditioning
units that's at least
$1,200 of an
upgrade to go to the higher efficiency
gas storage water heater at
$6,500 ladies and gentlemen let me be
really
clear our 27,000 people will build any
home you want it's your
choice if you want a net zero home tell
us we'll build
it we're working with you folks on an
Adu for 950 square feet we'll build
it we're consumer-driven
if you want it we'll build it but please
don't
mandate 76 million dollar of Consumer
Debt on home buyers in New Hampshire
especially
now so as you can tell I get a little
excited about that so I'll dial it back
um but we're here to work with you we
work with the
bcrb we live in New Hampshire we love
New Hampshire I'm GNA stop talking now
okay thank thank you are there any
questions from the committee pres
schmi can you be here for the
subcommittee Matt yes sir okay thank you
any other
questions oh repr long thank
you would this change uh discourage new
construction and if it would I guess how
much more efficient is the 2018 Building
Code versus
whatever new construction might be
replacing I'm a little confused
representative I'm sorry um so if if
we're at the 2018 energy code because
that's what this is about because we
already have the 21 Energy building code
so I can clarify so my one of my
concerns about this bill is that it
might discourage new construction
Although our housing market is hot
enough that I'm I'm not sure if it would
uh and I would assume that a house built
under the 2018 code while it's not as
efficient as the 20221 code would still
be more efficient than
whatever is already existing prior to
the 2018 code absolutely for those homes
that are built in 1950 1960 that you
know still plenty of yes of course you
know they're much more energy
efficient we'll still
build but you need to look at who you
want as
tenants because those costs are going to
get passed on dollar for dollar to the
tenant so those High rents are going to
go a little bit
higher those homes they're just now
become
$20,000 more
high so it won't stop the building but
it'll stop who's coming to the state
it'll stop who lives in the state it'll
stop who works in the
state representative
Dar thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my call uh question uh you
mentioned the ground Source heat pump as
being the most expensive item in the in
the new code uh can you talk about that
topic a little bit is it in the 18 code
the 21 code and the 24 code and briefly
what is it absolutely uh it's in the 24
code and it's
if I read
correctly that it is a um geothermal
heat
system so it would you know come through
the Earth cool or heat and come back up
and be recycle
through follow up and that's mandated in
the 24 code every every house will have
to have a
geothermal from the research I did in
the last 48 hours regarding
this I'm gonna pause sir I don't want to
misspeak I will find out and get you the
correct answer because I don't want to
mislead anyone thank
you would you like me to get back to you
sir please get back to the whole
committee because I think having the
question raised means we were all
interested in the answer I'm on the
subcommittee so I think you could bring
it to the subcommittee and then it'll
come back to the committee okay thank
you very much thank you madam chair
else sellers thank you madam
chair so why do we have an energy code
if we already have a building
code would shouldn't it be one and the
same sometimes a social
construct of people placing political
views into the public Arena drives
agendas we have folks who want to go to
Net Zero and green energy and um the
whole Myriad of issues so so they you
know send out the energy
code separately
so it is confusing that's why I took the
time talk about the building code is
2021 we're talking about the energy
code I'm not speaking that just it gets
really confusing to to some degree the
energy code sets requirements and the
building code gives the way to implement
the requirements like insulation I think
is one of them yes ma'am
um Mr M you said that according to
Senator
Shaheen the seven the 21 code Oppo
imposed about
$177,000 of costs above the 18 code and
the payback was $500 a year yes okay
well for the committee's delectation
that's a 34-year payback plus however
long it takes for the interest to borrow
the money up front um which would
approximately the same length of time in
in my experience
so um that's the interpretation of it
any other questions representative reeze
thank you I appreciated your offering um
the different numbers of debt that might
accumulate I'm deeply concerned about
the affordable housing crisis here in
New Hampshire but I'm I'm wondering um
if you are also prepared to offer any
comments or numbers about the indirect
cost born by everybody in the community
um that results from inefficient use of
energy and global warming and and
climate
change I think that would be describing
the color
blue up to
interpretation so I I don't want to
guess because I have facts for you folks
and you make fact-based
decisions any other
questions all right seeing n thank you
Mr mayber thank you madam chair
committee John
Gage hello chairwoman Community uh thank
you for taking my testimony today um I
just had a couple thoughts about that I
read a quick article on New Hampshire
Business Review Mar hop maian wrote that
um these changes from 2018 to 2021
expect to reduce uh to improve Energy
Efficiency by 10% um
and I think 177,000 sounds very high
from what I've read about the estimates
I've don't know but I've read three
$3,000 so I think you should get some um
more opinions about that um okay
so um I have written testimony
New Hampshire failed to update its bu
building efficiency codes last year
leaving the state behind our neighbors
in new building efficiency requirements
it's far cheaper to build Energy
Efficiency into a building during the
construction than to retrofit the
improvements later I just retrofitted my
own house which is 40 years old uh it
was
$99,000 to increase the insulation in
the the ceilings of a couple places and
in some walls uh and do other work um
it's much easier for the homeowner if
it's done ahead of time if buildings
cost a little more to build so Builders
don't like this change because their new
buildings compete with existing stock
however more energy efficient homes save
homeowners many times over the initial
construction cost in reducing energy
spending and more efficient homes are
more comfortable government intervention
is necessary to require Builders to
build more efficient homes the New
Hampshire economy will benefit from
doing so because it will let New
Hampshire homeowners save money they can
spend on things other than autostate
produced fossil
fuels and finally while the payback is
quick even under the current market
conditions the payback will be be even
quicker when it is no longer free to
pollute and that is increasingly likely
so it would be wise for New Hampshire to
anticipate a future carbon price on
fossil fuels which will drive higher
fossil fuel prices carbon pricing is
spreading around the world prices are
rising and SE bams are putting
increasing pressure on the US to price
carbon the US is now the only developed
country without a carbon price and other
countries and regions are about to start
charging us for our free pollution when
we do trade with them Federal carbon
pricing is inevitable and New Hampshire
should both prepare for it and tell
Congress to do it with a good policy
like carbon fee and dividend to protect
New Hampshire citizens and businesses
and hold other countries accountable
sorry I have some
handouts thank you for that and the U
since it is going to subcommittee we'll
have plenty of time to read this and you
don't have to read it to us okay that
was all I'm done reading um so the hand
out so what I'm going to try to do is
convince you that the US government is
going to have to price carbon in the
next 10
years and the reason that it's important
to convince you that that's happening is
that if we continue using the 2018
building codes and building more stock
that is not 10% more efficient um what
is a missed opportunity already is going
to become a bigger missed opportunity
and hardship for families especially low
and middle-income families um that are
in new houses that are already obsolete
as far as their building efficiency so
um 75 countries and regions are pricing
carbon that's about triple the number
from a dozen years or so ago um prices
are rising the EU price is around $70
per ton of CO2 Canada is about the same
and they're Rising um the
International Panel on climate change
has a minimum carbon price that's
required globally to have a chance to
meet our climate goals the US price is
still zero except for a few States um
our major trading partners are on that
Rising price path um they know what it
is and they're getting to the point of a
high enough price where it becomes a
trade problem for them and that's where
cbm's carbon border adjustments come in
so the European Union is the first
country that will Implement a cbam in
2026 it actually was implemented two
years ago on paper us exporters of
energy intensive Goods steel cement
aluminum Plastics have to calculate the
embedded emissions in their products
from producing it in the US so that when
they sell it to the EU they calculate
what their carbon footprint of that
product is so that in 2026 when the EU
starts charging their CBM they will pay
the EU on um when us goods go into the
EU economy um the UK's CVM starts in
2027 Japan's CBM starts in 2028
Australia is looking at doing this and
Canada is looking at doing this um so
the US businesses don't have this on the
horizon yet but when they start actually
having to pay other countries and those
prices are rising they will be subject
to a competitive disadvantage as other
countries are decarbonizing using the
most effective methods and US carbon
footprint products are not so New
Hampshire should be anticipating a
federal carbon price a price on
pollution um there's good ways to do
this that are Revenue neutral and hold
other countries accountable but the
thing that you guys thinking about this
bill um should realize is that the
energy Market is changing why do
efficiency codes and billing codes kind
of mean you know why are they done
together as one thing uh because that is
an it's an integral to the building that
people buy it's not just a frame and
walls uh it's also how much it cost to
operate um by increasing our Energy
Efficiency in new buildings um we're
anticipating changes in the energy
Market that we cannot avoid uh and all
homeowners that buy these houses will
will greatly appreciate it thank you can
can I interpret your comments to say
that you're expecting energy cost to
rise significantly and is not considered
in
other other issues that's correct if you
look at the single page sheet uh one of
the sides has statements from all the
major fossil fuel um producers they all
agree climate change from their product
is happening they all agree that carbon
pricing is the The Logical market-based
approach to solve it and this is
happening on a quarter of all the fossil
fuels that are sold in the world and
it's spreading so yes I so we can do it
with carbon fee and dividend returning
the money collected from fossil fuel
producers so people come out ahead was
the an thank you the answer is yes does
anyone else have questions repr of
Howard thank you for taking my question
uh so when you were initially talking
about some of the upgrades that you
performed on your home you said that
$9,000 uh was spent on your 40-year home
what was the original cost of that home
uh I bought it
used well yes but how much did you
pay 187,000 I think all right wonderful
uh could I have follow follow up all
right wonderful and how much do you
believe you have made back each year uh
due to these
upgrades well I just made them this
Summer uh so there hasn't been much time
for payback except the upstairs is 5
warmer than it was before with the heat
set in the same level um I pulled out my
heating of water and put in a heat pump
water system in the basement um I
constantly run a dehumidifier in the
basement all summer long um to keep it
dry this is automatic dehumidification
dehumid dehumidification in the
summertime uh as it operates it
naturally pulls water out of the air as
it's heating the water so it's taking
care of
um I won't know the cost what the the
guy that uh installed the whole system
and did I replaced my furnace too that
broke too it was a expensive year last
year um thought I would be burning 50%
less oil and the heating of the water
would be much cheaper than it was when I
was using oil to heat it um so my home
is more
comfortable I wish the house had been
built to the standards that I am trying
now I can't get it to to that but I I
hit the most important parts it's a lot
it's a lot of hassle you have to deal
with contractors yourself these guys are
brilliant they know how to build
buildings I had to learn heating systems
and vapor barriers and we did blower
tests and like how much do I want to
spend versus um the the US agencies that
made these 2021 building efficiency
standards looked at cost and
availability of what it what these
standards would do to the building stock
and uh
it didn't make a difference they they
deter you know part of developing the
standard is to not break things and and
so that calculation has been done and I
believe other states around us are
already using these codes um and they
don't seem to be having problems we do
seem to be the donut hole in New England
as far as Energy Efficiency goes and
people moving into the state will think
that do you want to live in a a cheap to
to operate house that's comfortable in
Vermont or Maine or massachusett sits or
do you want to go into New Hampshire and
you're kind of on their own because
their efficiency codes are out of date
and um you know you might save a couple
bucks when you buy the house but you're
going to pay uh year after year um for
that
luxury all right thank you so
much other questions thank you very much
Mr Gage Alex katris
thank you madam chair members of the
committee my name is Alex kbis I'm with
the associated general contractors of
New Hampshire I replaced Gary Abbott
this summer so I'm about six months in
the new role so please be gentle with me
it's it's actually my first Hearing in
the new uh in the new position we are
opposed to this legislation and I just
want to remind the committee and it's
kind of been said before but I don't
know how explicit listed it's been in
2024 House Bill 1059 which I've handed
out handed out the committee report in
the docket this committee voted 20 to
zero to not adopt the 2021 energy code
that was last year and as you can see
it's in the committee report and I
looked up the vote the building code
review board voted 9 to4 to not adopt
the 2021 energy code last year in 2024
so this committee and the experts on the
building code review committee rejected
the 2021 building code a very short time
ago uh Governor cunu signed House Bill
1059 in August of last year so not that
long ago so we're already we're already
back again I don't know really what's
changed all that much in the last few
months but but here we are I also handed
out an article from the conquered
monitor that talks about a housing
development in the South End of conquer
and it was a multiphas
uh apartment building you can see if you
read the article the rents are very uh
affordable for one in two-bedroom homes
and the developer talks about in the
article High interest rates and high
construction costs have put that the
additional phases of that project in
Jeopardy because he's saying the
construction costs are too high and a
bill like this has the potential I think
significant potential to add
construction costs and put some of these
important housing projects at risk uh as
I said the the building code Review
Committee really they're the experts
that that um should be reviewing these
Bill these uh these types of bills
before they go to the legislature we
would certainly urge the committee to
not do anything in in the 2025 session
and wait until the review is done in
June perhaps we can look at doing
something in
2026 uh but just as a reminder that the
jump to the 2018 codes was was a pretty
significant jump
in terms of the types of requirements
that were put on Builders uh these tests
as you heard can cost thousands of
dollars the upgrades can cost thousands
of dollars and I agree with everything
that the home builder said these costs
are just going to get passed on to the
users of these buildings whether they're
in in rent or owning situations uh it
can take decades to recoup the cost of
the initial investment and we want the
consumers to have the choice uh
we we'll build the Taj Mahal if that's
what people want but it may not be
affordable for everyone so we want
people to have the choice if you want a
significantly energy efficient home or
commercial building we will we will
build to that if you want something that
that just meets the code or or somewhere
in between we want to work with the
individuals that purchase these these
buildings um so that that's really all I
have to say I'm happy to provide my
written testimony but again we would
just urge from the commercial side uh
let let's let the building code Review
Committee complete its work which you
heard is not going to be done until June
and perhaps we could look at some kind
of compromise where we adopt pieces of
21 and 24 but we just don't think this
bill is ready for for prime time happy
to participate in the subcommittee I'm
even happy to see if I can get a
commercial builder at the at the meeting
to see there's more questions in detail
that you'd like to ask that individual
I'm happy to try to do that if you think
it's helpful to
committee thank
you are questions from the
committee all right seeing none thank
you and we look for at the subcommittee
Paul
beamus we're
gonna together I believe with Bruce um
okay you're Bruce butrick yes okay thank
you thank you that'll
uh else spe it up
yes that's that's what I
meant thank you madam chair committee
members my name is Bruce butrick I live
in
Goffstown I'm here as a resident but
also because I belong to a engineering
industry
Association ashray American Society of
heating Refrigeration air conditioning
Engineers it's
International and its memberships about
55,000 people I'm not representing them
but I use their standards one of their
standards being the standard aashray
90.1 which is the energy code primarily
in the commercial function of it but
there are some residential elements of
that as well also
there's the international energy
conservation code the
iecc which is um produced by the
International Code Council which is a
big umbrella of all the building codes
and I'm going to say building codes
meaning Plumbing electrical well not
electrical um the mechanical
hvc um building and some fire codes so
it's a very convoluted thing bucket to
put in as building codes but I'll give
you a little background of
myself um I'm retired but I started out
after college working for mechanical
engineering firm in Boston and with that
entailed working with mechanical codes
fire protection and building
codes as well as the ashray being a
function having standards for
refrigeration
whatever um after several years I went
and went to
the contractor's side as project manager
for a mechanical contractor in
Manchester after that I went to the dark
side and became a building inspector
specifically a mechanical inspector city
of nashar for 15 years plus that was
primarily gas piping and
HVAC and most recently I morphed into a
land use zoning administrator and
finished out my career
with that I'll introduce Paul in a bit
I'm going to work on the elements of the
policy of energy codes and the
benefits and I wanted to alert or
reference the handout the first page I
went online to see what the testimony
was and as of 10 o'clock there were 45
that supported this bill six that
opposed it so there is some good
support for this at least addressing the
energy code and possibility of adopting
that
um as I said the energy code function
from ashray is collaborated with the ICC
and it becomes the iecc international
energy code conservation code which has
a residential element as well as the
commercial
element so my speech is the second
handout and basically it's the benefits
of adopting energy
codes as we know energy codes are
regulatory I'm not going to read the
whole thing just the highlights so you
spared that energy codes are regulatory
standards um basically the uh energies
to improve the energy code is to prove
Energy Efficiency of buildings and
thereby reducing the energy consumption
the demand and the greenhouse gas
emissions whatever simply put
it's the worst house you can legally
build when you have a building code
energy code plumbing code it's the floor
level it's a D minus it's the minimum
minimum that's all we're asking for is
that minimum standard to have to build
to to achieve the benefits of all the
building codes and the inry codes so
what's what are the benefits the
environmental benefits reduction of
greenhouse gases by setting Energy
Efficiency standards for buildings these
codes Ure that less energy is consumed
for heating cooling lighting and other
operational
needs this in turn leads to a decrease
in the burning of fossil
fuels conservation of Natural Resources
the implementation of energy codes help
conserve natural resources by decreasing
the demand for energy improved air
quality lower energy consumption the
demand means there's fewer emissions
from the power plants which in turn
results in clean cleer
air the economic benefits the cost
savings energy efficient buildings
require less energy to operate which
translate into lower utility builds from
a mechanical designer standpoint the
tight energy efficient building I didn't
have to provide a bigger heating plant
it was reduced for that heat loss for
the load of the building I didn't have
to provide as large a mechanical system
systems because of that efficient
building
shell The increased energy security we
would like to have energy independence
energy efficient buildings help
stabilize the energy grid by decreasing
the peak demand which can prevent
blackouts reduce the need for costly
infrastructure upgrades and then the
societal
benefits it enhanced the comfort and
well-being we improved the insulation
the ventilation and temperature control
system
it ensures that the indoor spaces are
kept at optimal conditions regardless of
the external weather conditions today's
a great
example and the benefits that taxpayer
the energy code ensures that all
buildings especially State and municipal
buildings that are built and owned that
they meet minimum energy performance
standards this directly benefits the
taxpayers as energy efficient buildings
are less costly to
operate so in conclusion
the adoption and implementation of
energy codes should be a priority for
policy makers the industry stakeholders
and the general public alike as we
collectively strive towards a more
energy efficient
World um so I basically did
the benefits of the energy code Paul's
the numbers guy he's the real
engineer and I'm going to let Paul there
was one a question that I'm going to
answer because I did get involved with
codes codes adoptions whatever when the
building codes and the energy codes
plumbing codes change from one edition
to another Edition say the 18 to
21 I'm going to say the mother the um
the organizers that are writing these
they will do substantial changes from
that version to another version or us as
inspectors we' know oh my gosh this this
changed there a cheat sheet you know
two-page whatever what changed from that
code to that code so we'd know that okay
we've got to get into a new program of
the new code they never had the numbers
of how much is that incremental cost
going to do to incur those
changes um other than that that's
basically and again the number of codes
the international codes were kind of
like a family of codes and that's why
they rolled them into the plumbing code
the mechanic code the fire code and the
building code because sometimes s in the
building code it said you can um design
fabricate the egress exits in accordance
to the fire code and then make your
reference to another code that
complements that code that you're on so
if you happen to break them apart from
the 21 to an 18 it can get disjointed
and it doesn't meld well and that's one
of my concerns of having to stay on the
18 is we got left by behind we may not
mesh well with the 21s which are
currently
adopted so I think I'm finished with my
spu and I'm going to go to the
numbers uh thank you madam chair for
having both of us here and members of
the committee my name is Paul
beamus I um am an engineer mechanical
engineer undergrad University of New
Hampshire graduate school electrical
engineering at North Eastern University
and uh also an MBA I I own a company
called applied math modeling we do
mathematical modeling for high
performance data centers so I'm a
building scientist and involved with
building science uh most of my adult
life I wanted to uh testify today that
the in favor of this bill h96 the 2021
codes are quite important for a number
of reasons Bruce mentioned a number of
these including of course Energy
Efficiency and cost savings there's
another big one that uh we often don't
talk about human health uh if you have a
building that has proper insulation and
a proper Vapor Barrier which are the two
key things in the 2021 code compared to
the 2018 code you have a home that is
much more comfortable and you have
humans who are much healthier this is
because mostly The Vapor Barrier keeps
humidity both in and out in the winter
time like today it keeps humidity in so
that you can operate in the 40 to 60%
relative humidity range that is required
to make humans healthy if you drop below
40% which a leaky building will do uh
that will cause problems with your
immune system because it dries out the
silica in your upper respiratory system
that is used to defend yourself against
Airborne pathogens in addition uh
Airborne pathogens generally if the
humidity is high will be wet and will
fall to the ground when it's dry they
don't they float in the atmosphere here
and you can ingest them and become sick
this is a leading cause of Airborne
transmission uh from diseases ranging
from sinful influenza to covid-19 to the
measles to the common flu indoor air
quality is important from not just a
quality of environment and comfort point
of view it is important from a human
health point of
view now just speaking to the issue of
cost there's been a lot of discussion
about high cost
the studies that have been done by the
depart on behalf of the Department of
energy by the Pacific National Northwest
lab which is one of the best labs in the
country I know them I've worked with
them they've been my customer a number
of times indicates the cost to go from
the 2018 code to the 2021 code is
$2,350 it's not a big number it's a
small number
$2,300 uh furthermore uh when you go to
the 2021 code you have as Bruce pointed
out a smaller footprint of heating and
cooling which means you can reduce the
size of your heating and cooling system
an example of this is a new home I went
and visited in Maine who did conform to
the 2021 codes to give you an example
the home is equivalent to approximately
my size of my home about 2600 Square ft
a modest home they were heating it with
33,000 BTUs
a mine takes 100,000 factor of three
more to heat and cool my home compared
to theirs because it was built to the
standards so the studies that uh are
credible suggest a savings as stated by
John of uh
$531 a year in average cost savings for
this geography but that's on an
investment of $2,300 not
$20,000 $2,300 we're talking here
predominantly about the amount of
insulation the ceiling goes to R50 the
walls go to
R30 the subfloor gets insulated as well
once you have your building insulated it
will sustain its temperature so that on
a cold night like last night we went
through you get up in the morning and
your home is or office or commercial
building is roughly the same temperature
as it was when you left because it rides
it's called a thermal ride the ability
to ride through the night because it has
mass the mass has temperature it holds
on to it because it's not dumping it to
the
atmosphere I think many of us woke up
today to a cool environment in our homes
uh if it wasn't cold in it it's because
you were burning a lot of probably
fossil fuel and it was probably cold in
certain sections conforming to the 2021
code would eliminate that the home would
have a constant uniform temperature
throughout it this is very important for
not only human health but Energy
Efficiency uh this is true in all of our
commercial buildings it's true also in
our public buildings it's true in our
schools uh the other thing these codes
do 2021 in particular is it puts in a
way to get fresh air into the building
and it absorbs the Heat going out so
that it doesn't get dumped to the
atmosphere it's better than opening the
window because it takes the heat that's
leaving the building and transfers it to
the incoming air through an energy
recovery ventilator that gives you fresh
clean air and still maintains the same
thermal
environment so there are many reasons
why the 2021 code makes a lot of sense
if we continue to wait and study the
2024 code we're going to miss the
opportunity to update these homes and
buildings that are being built now and
going back and trying to retrofit them
is extremely expensive imagine trying to
insulate a subfloor once it's been
poured it's virtually impossible you
have to Jackhammer it and try to do it
or even the walls as John pointed out in
an older home or ceilings very hard to
do once the building's built but during
the construction of the building putting
a little more insulation in it putting
an improved vapor barrier in it or on it
will improve it and make it last longer
one other point about vapor barriers is
that it extends the life of the building
if moisture is coming in and say it's
cold inside it's going to hit the cold
condensate and make mold same thing on
the way out if it's cold out and you're
warm in moisture is going to go back out
through the wall hit the cold make mold
pollute the environment it's going to
rot the wood happens over and over and
over we've seen it many many times if
you have a proper Vapor Barrier it
cannot happen because moist moisture
can't pass it so keeping the humidity in
the environments constant or at least
within the range of 40 to 60 is
important for human health keeping the
temperature constant is a human comfort
factor both of them tend to reduce the
energy footprint to the point where you
can operate with a
lower heating cooling ventilation
equipment this has been proven over and
over
again um in fact fact I want to just uh
while I'm testifying read a statement
from James Peterson James Peterson is
one of the key builders in the state
Peterson engineering their design Bill
firm out of
Portsmouth dear legislators I am writing
in support of the adoption of the 2020
energy code my name is James Peterson
I've been practicing professional
engineering in the state of New
Hampshire since
1991 resident of Portsmouth completed to
term of the New Hampshire code review
board in the past my Ste and my myself
and my staff have 24 engineers and
support staff are experts in energy and
buildings energy use and buildings in
summary designing buildings to the 20201
energy C code improves Energy Efficiency
the building enclosures and separates
the indoors from the outdoors the
enclosure improvements costs increments
are offset by the reduced Heating and
Cooling equipment in system Capital cost
unrelated but important other perks
include the buildings that are healthier
more comfortable for occupants more
durable simpler easier to maintain and
can continue to be occupied long after
an event has knocked out the heating and
cooling or taken an offline such as a
grid failure or the inability to get
fuel for some reason due to a
catastrophic case this is in contrast to
existing buildings that require
evacuation during cold weather if the
heat goes off during a coold snap
because the pipes will
freeze James Peterson so I'm here to
Advocate uh for no personal reason I
don't have
a an agenda here I there's no money
involved with my situation I own a
software company but I'm a building
scientist I understand why these codes
have been put in place I would adopt I
would encourage the adoption of this
house bill uh as quickly as we can do
it I can also answer some questions that
came up earlier if you would like U ones
that you were asking
about cost I already touched upon cost
$2,300 is the estimated cost of the
incremental increase associated with it
I'd also like that's from 18 to 21 18 to
21 that is correct thank you I'd also
like to point out that uh if you finance
your home which is quite normal the
payback in terms of cash is quite quick
The increased down payment would be
$41 due to the $2,300 increment an
increase of six a cost of $61 but the
saving is is
$537 per year so you're positive cash in
two years total payback in six simple
payback in six because the numbers are
fairly modest it's fairly
small I did I did review the report that
was referenced by Mr Mayberry and the
report and the study that was done was
heavily SL Ed in favor of a
predetermined outcome um it seemed as
though the people who were creating it
wanted the numbers to look bad as an
example they used a price of energy that
was extremely low they used natural gas
for example we don't all use natural gas
here many people use oil and they used a
number that was very very small when
they went to look at cost they took the
worst possible case in terms of cost
increase and added that on and so the
payback period looked bad
so it was a simple case of trying to
make the numbers look like they wanted
to be a predetermined
outcome since then there's been a couple
of journalists that I could reference
who have looked into this and found out
the study was financed by the National
Gas Association of the United States of
America it's fossil fuel and uh it's not
just New Hampshire this is a campaign
ashray has been uh dealing with this
issue this is a campaign that's gone on
around the country uh the fossil fuel
people want you to consume fossil fuels
ex you don't you can't know their motive
so please don't impune them facts are
fine but no motives
okay um ground Source heat pump came up
as a question a ground Source heat pump
is simply a device that pulls the energy
out of the earth effectively the Earth
runs at about 50 degrees most of the
time nearly all the time if you're
trying to get your home to 70 you simply
use the 50 to go to the 70 it's a
difference of 20 that's what it does it
pulls the heat out of the earth to heat
the home the 2024 code does not mandate
it but no one would ever mandate what
kind of heating cooling system you would
have there are different types there's
an air source heat pump many people have
them I got one from my home it is a a
air-to-air system sits on the side of
the house so you can use air as the
source but on a cold day that air like
to day is -3 a little hard to pull heat
out of a minus33 dee air but the ground
is 50 so ground sour SE pumps are more
efficient from an energy point of view
but the capital cost is higher because
you have to drill a well and they put a
loop down in the well and pull the heat
out of the water is how they actually do
it very efficient people love them but
the capital cost is fairly high for
those um benefits I think Bruce went
over most of the benefits one of them
I'll add is life of the building goes
way up there's an estimated 20 degree uh
20y year increase in the life of the
building because moisture is not going
back and forth through the walls and
rotting the walls so you don't have mold
problems you don't have rot because you
have a proper vapor barrier in
place
um I think that was a few of them at
least
questions are there questions
representative Leo um thank you madam
chair and thank you for bringing this to
us um I in my spare time like to read
things like Green Building advisor and I
was definitely very interested following
their process with finding the correct
location of the vapor barrier and if
that's located in the wrong place based
upon the level of insulation in the
house you may actually cause new
structural problems is that something
that's now been solved because quite
frankly I haven't read that in the last
year or so but I do know that that was a
significant problem for a building yes
it has been solved um the idea on a
vapor Berry is put it outside let the
wall breathe to the inside um you can do
it the other way but that's generally
how it's been solved is to put it on the
outside uh high performance buildings
today will basically wrap them uh the
one in Maine I reviewed had a
rubber wrapper on it and they encased it
on the outside let the room breathe to
the inside that allows the drying to
take place mold and rot will happen if
it doesn't dry so you have to put it all
the way out to the outside and then put
rain screen so that the water hitting
the clapboards or whatever can drain and
dry and then let the vapor dry to the
inside from that barrier the answer is
yes follow and as a followup um does
that also requ um is that conditional on
the quality of the in installation
because I've seen those vapor barriers
flapping In The Wind that were never
approp rely um connected and it's my
understanding that those pin holes
actually have a larger water intrusion
because um we won't get into the nerdy
side of this but um you are right you've
been studying um this this goes to the
issue of commissioning commissioning is
something that we don't require today
the the bill that's been introduced by a
representative here H HB the house bill
96 requires commissioning we put it back
in because commissioning is the testing
of the building and you are quite right
if you do not test it you don't know if
you've achieved the goal so testing is
an extremely important component of all
of this stuff we test for structural we
test for smoke we test for many many
things we're going to put a vapor
barrier on and not test for it at all so
we would Advocate that testing should
occur at the end of a cycle to ensure
that the building meets the criteria
that set forth in the
specification um is that actually part
of the 21 energy code for for houses
commissioning always has been y it's in
there it's
actually um it's been in the energy
codes many many years the state New
Hampshire has amended it out probably
for the last 10 years as an older
standard and it keeps coming back every
year as a c every three years as a
carryover Amendment than it really
shouldn't be for the commercial side
thank you what represent
bre Mr beamus beus B M did I get that
right um you mentioned the study that
estimated believe it was I think you
said 2350 or or
$2,372 and you you cited the um author
of that study could you repeat that for
me I didn't Pacific Northwest National
Laboratory Pacific Northwest Norwest PN
NL Pacific Northwest National
Laboratory they are one of the big doe
uh uh research facilities out of uh
Oregon I believe and uh they do an awful
lot of energy modeling they're
responsible for the gold standard for
energy uh modeling called doe2 do2 codes
that are used by everybody in the world
to model the efficiency of
buildings p out um quickly well
hopefully quickly um the and and who
find you mentioned who financed the
other study uh natural I think it was
natural gas who finances that is it a is
it a federal federally funded program
yes it's a it's actually ashray does a
lot of the funding we we we raise money
for for that so it's funded through
organizations including ashray yeah okay
thank you you're welcome okay other
questions seeing none thank thank you
very much thank
you representative Schmidt sorry did you
have a question well I do know so
you've given us a lot of
scientific explanation for a number of
the issues that we're confronting here
uh but you undoubtedly have listened as
we were listen other people before you
uh with regard to a subcommittee meeting
that will be com hence forth
uh to work through these problems that
we have been uh hearing about today uh
you've come from I don't see your PIN
card uh where are you both from I am
from uh Bristol New Hampshire I'm the
chair of the Bristol energy committee as
well uh my family dates back 300 years
in this uh in this state back when I was
a kid okay and I'm Bruce butrick and I'm
from gtown okay I'm retired I do have
time if it's possible I think I would
volunteer some member from our local
chapter of ashray it'll be in the
calendar when the subcommittee perfect
oh great thank you it will be noticed at
any
rate okay thank you very much thank you
for your time
today Chris scogland
okay good morning uh good afternoon
members of the committee my name is uh
and fortunately chair McGuire has seen
me testify on this topic many many times
um I am the director of energy
transition from clean energy New
Hampshire we are not a trade
organization as many people think we
actually have uh there are five 1c3 that
includes our members all three Electric
utilities all the Gas Utilities in the
state 43 municipalities representing
approximately 430,000 state representa
state
represent residents not
representatives and we also have 130
businesses that are our members as well
our goal is to advance a clean
affordable reliable energy in the state
and Energy Efficiency is a primarily uh
element of that realizing that this is
going to go to a subcommittee and we've
been in this room for almost an hour and
a half um I'll keep my remarks brief and
just uh note that I've been following
this process possibly longer than anyone
else in this room with the exception of
uh chair McGuire uh we've been follow
I've been working on this since about
2009 when I started with the state um
following the building of code viiew
board throughout that process and I'm
familiar with the adoption of the 2015
2018 and 2021 codes and so a few things
that I just wanted to kind of draw
attention to um
the data that was represent referenced
regarding Senator Shaheen although I've
been here almost long enough that she
was governor when I started um actually
she is quoted at the value that very was
very similar to what Paul vimma said at
about $2,300 in added costs and $500 in
annual savings as opposed to a $177,000
value so I would recommend that the
subcommittee gets together that any data
that is shared it comes fully cited um
and is documented who the authors are uh
as that as was noted by other speakers
we've got a number of studies out there
and who the authors are and where the
funding comes from is important um I
also wanted to note that the building
code for the state which is found in RSA
155a section 4 so Roman numeral 4 the
definition of the building code code
includes the plumbing code the
electrical code The Mechanical Code the
building code the existing building code
the fire code the pool and spa code and
the energy code the energy code is a
chapter of the state's overall building
code so it is not separate but it is an
essential element to give you an idea of
how essential if there is no energy code
we basically live in shells that leak
all of the heat out or cooled air in the
summer very quickly in our unlivable
structures so without the energy code we
basically just have um the shed that my
chickens are currently suffering through
this weather
in um but we to get back to our point do
support the adoption of the 2021 code
because it is in advance over the 2018
code when we adopted the 2018 code in
2022 there was virtually no benefit in
advancing from the 2015 to the 2018 code
the 2015 code was a significant jump in
efficiency which meant that there was a
significant savings to all homes that
were built under that standard the 2018
code was more of an administrative
change that cleaned up some of the ways
that the building code was administered
by building officials the 2021 code is
in advance and that it does add some
cost but some that that total cost is
quoted in by Senator Sheen as well as
the Pacific Northwest National Lab at
about $2,300 with significant savings
for a homeowner on day one but but
that's for an average house of 2 2400 ft
if we're talking about affordable
housing the cost is going to be smaller
and that's for a
2400t detached single family home if
it's in uh affordable housing the
building size will like or the footprint
will be smaller but the cost to the
consumer will also be smaller even if
they are seeing a similar
benefit um and so the 2021 code was
largely held up
um due to arguments that were made at
the building code review board but I
will note that the building code review
board does not have a consumer Advocate
or a building scientist on it instead it
includes members of Industry who are
being lobbied by mil members of industry
and so the conversation may happen there
in front of experts but there are
specific interests that are brought
before that board that may not get to
all the facts the fact that there is not
a consumer voice on that board is very
important and should be taken into
consideration when hearing the facts
before you so I'll close and note that
we would ask that the 2021 code because
it does deliver real savings that are
paid back in a very short amount of time
do be Advanced and that the 2024 code
not be an amendment made to this bill
allow the building code review board to
continue their conversation uh they have
not finished reviewing it um we will be
arguing for an unamended 2024 code in
front of that body but for this one uh
we should stick with the 2021 code and
then keep it
in consist consistent with the rest of
the chapters of the states building code
but we are happy to bring more
information to that subcommittee and
we'll be looking for it to be
noticed thank you are there any
questions yes for long you mentioned
renters in your handout here do you have
a sense of what percentage of renters
have to pay for their electricity
directly versus having it rolled into
the rent we
I do not but I can look that up and see
I do know that there is a challenge it's
called the split incentive where uh the
building code ends up being a consumer
protection mechanism so the building
energy code does because developers that
are building homes that they're going to
rent out if they're not paying the
electric bill may not have the incentive
to build to that higher standard knowing
that renters we have a 05% vacancy rate
in the state we don't get to pick and
choose where uh we live I have friends
or students at UNH that are trying to
find housing and it's very hard they're
taking what they can find so it ends up
being consumer protection especially for
residents because they don't get to pick
to the design the features they get to
pick what's available and so
oh well uh I only said electricity but I
meant to include heat that question as
well I I know that when I was renting um
my landlord asked me why our bill was so
low uh because he was paying it and he
just wanted to know how we could get the
other renters to do the same
thing represent Leon thank you madam
chair um and uh thank you for bringing
up chicken coops I actually built
Fortress fowl which was ridiculously
overbuilt with rain gaps and insulation
um but that actually ties back to your
discussion about the average 2400 foot
house versus affordable housing uh
because every linear foot of that
insulation was actually insulating less
of the Interior Space so while you made
be building a is it correct that while
you may be building a smaller home for
an affordable house uh you still you may
have you have a different ratio of your
wall space so the instulation cost
higher per square foot well it depends
affordable housing can include multi
family housing and so the units adjacent
to you can actually buffer against and
therefore increase the total mass of the
space reduce the surface area to volume
ratio and therefore make the building
overall more efficient it may not feel
as spacious but that does factor in cost
so the the per unit cost will depend on
whether you're building a tiny house or
whether you're building a 2400 average
home or you're building a multi family
uh unit that is three stories and above
and therefore subject to the commercial
energy code thank you okay other
questions all right thank you very much
thank you we'll see you in committee is
there anyone else who wishes to testify
on House Bill 96
okay not seeing any I'm going to close
the public hearing uh afraid it will
have to go to
subcommittee and
um we are done for the day resuming 10
o'clock
tomorrow I won't do this but I'm tempted
to address the committee this take about
60 seconds I have a dlex in
450,000 out the numbers I
need I don't
believe I don't believe the 2300
and it's amazing what this incandescent
can do 0% of yeah but and that's the
thing if we're heating our homes it's
actually not terrible there's small heat
sources
exactly thank
you sorry I have a brother who's a
materials engineer so yes a car me
anything actually you should give one to
represent of shean because she's she's
the chair of the sub to
my e